Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Brittler und ich begrüße
zu einer weiteren Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsserie und vor allem einer weiteren
Ausgabe der Gespräche, die ich hier auf meiner Podcast-Reise über die kanarischen
Inseln führe und ähm ja mittlerweile hat es mich auf die Insel La Palma verschlagen. Sitze hier grad schön mit äh Blick auf die Überbleibsel des ausgebrochenen Vulkans, alles äh sehr hübsch. Hatte aber auch schon noch ein paar
andere schöne Besuche, dazu gleich mehr. Worum geht's heute? Heute geht's um
spezielles Teleskop, das Granteleskopio de Canarias oder wie man hier so schön sagt, das Grante Can, das äh nicht weniger ist als das größte optische Bodenteleskop der Welt, zumindest noch und äh ja um darüber
im Detail zu sprechen, begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Stefan Geier. Hallo Stefan.
Ja Stefan, du äh wohnst ja hier auf äh La Palma und es ist immer schön warm, meistens zumindest. Schon eine Weile, ne?
Ja ähm
zu deinem Kommentar, dass wir es immer schön warm haben ähm gerade Wind, das war mit dem Klima, es gibt ja keine Heizungen hier typischerweise, das heißt also wenn's wirklich mal äh kälter wird, dann wird's schon ein bissel ungemütlich dann zu Hause, aber das ist,
äh wir sagen ja es gibt kein schlechtes Wetter, sondern nur unangemessene Kleidung. Also das ist wirklich ein Luxusproblem hier, ja.
Ja, wir wollen heute äh über Bodenteleskope sprechen, beziehungsweise eben um speziell über das
einem Boden Teleskop, Bodenteleskope beim Warum zeigt schon äh mehrfach ein Thema äh in Raumzeit äh achtundsechzig
ganz allgemein um bodengestützte Astronomie und äh viel um Teles
da ist das GTC äh glaube ich bestenfalls am Rande äh erwähnt worden. Haben wir viel über die natürlich gesprochen und die äh Teleskope auf Hawaii und ähm ja auch in Raumzeit,
vierundneunzig ähm ging's ja um die Weltraumbeobachtung und die Wissenschaft im weiteren Sinne, da war ich in Madrid und habe mit,
auch darüber gesprochen, wie ähm
das alles so organisiert ist und auch das wird heute ein Thema sein, aber wir wollen natürlich vor allem über das Teleskop selber sprechen. Aber kommen wir doch erstmal äh zu dir, Stefan,
Ähm du bist äh am GTC, wie man auch sagt, am Grante kann ähm als
Support Astrona. Das heißt, du bist eigentlich tatsächlich auch selbst äh Astronom, was das genau studiert ursprünglich?
Ja ich habe Physik studiert.
Es ist äh Astronomio oder Astrophysik gibt's ja nicht als eigenes Studienfach, zumindest in Deutschland. Also der Weg äh um Astronomie als Beruf zu betreiben,
darüber Physik zu studieren, dann natürlich als Wahlfach im Hauptstudium auch Physik zu machen und.
Dann auch äh dann mit einer Diplomarbeit auf dem Gebiet abzuschließen, dann später eine Doktorarbeit anzuschließen und eigentlich mit dem Doktor grad gilt man dann eigentlich auch offiziell dann als Astronom beziehungsweise Astrophysiker.
Mhm. Dein Doktorarbeit, da ging's um Galaxien, wenn ich mich richtig äh informiert habe.
Galaxien bei hoher Rotverschiebung.
Also weit weg.
Sozusagen, ja.
Aha. Was hast du dir da angeschaut?
Wir haben den Punkt, den man vielleicht erwähnen, dass äh.
Sehr große Entfernungen äh sehen, also in dem Fall Milliarden von Lichtjahren, dass wir in dem Fall weit in die Vergangenheit,
ja? Ähm die Entfernung zu einem Objekt in Lichtjahren angegeben. Man sagt uns ja nichts anderes, also wie viele Jahre das Objekt zur zu uns entfernen war. Das heißt also
Bei Entfernungen von Milliarden von Lichtern schauen wir daneben auch äh viele Milliarden Jahre dann in der Vergangenheit.
Eben wie äh Galaxien im frühen Universum ausgesehen haben.
Aber was hast du dir in der Doktorarbeit angeschaut? Das äh war mal eine Frage.
Genauso da ging's konkret um Galaxien, um Rotation zwei ungefähr, um das mal ähm sozusagen zu übersetzen zu einer Zeit, die ungefähr,
zehn Milliarden Jahre her ist jetzt, dass ungefähr
3 und 4 Milliarden Jahren nach dem Urknall. Das ist eine sehr interessante Zeit in der Entstehung und Evolution äh von Galaxien.
Was macht ihr so interessant die Zeit.
Ja gut, allein der Umstand, dass er das Universum nicht ewig in in seiner jetzigen Form, in seinem jetzigen Zustand existiert haben, sondern eben nach unserer jetzigen Erkenntnis eben mal mit dem Urknall begonnen hat, was auch immer der Urknall war.
Heißt eben, dass die Galaxien, so wie in so sehr Milchstaus und andere Galaxien im heutigen Universum eben nicht immer so waren, wie sie jetzt sind, sondern eben in der Frühzeit des Universums entstanden sind und sich dann entwickelt haben. Das heißt also, wenn man
soweit zurück sieht, sieht man eben äh andere,
Typen von Galaxien sozusagen, die dann natürlich die Vorläufer von Galaxien im heutigen Universum sind, also ist es natürlich sehr wichtig äh
Damals ausgesehen haben, um ein besseres Bild äh zu kriegen wie Galaxien entstanden sind und sich entwickelt haben.
Sehr viele offene Fragen, ne.
Habe ich mich ja hier auch mit Helmut unterhalten. Kollege äh von dir auf der anderen Insel, auf Teneriffa, der das ja zur Spezialität hat,
Aber dann äh bist du irgendwie hier hängen geblieben. Wie was äh was für einen Weg hast du den genommen bis bis du dann hierher gekommen bist?
Ja gut, hängengeblieben, klingt vielleicht bissel zu ne.
Es war keine Wertung.
Gut ähm es war eigentlich immer schon ein Traum von mir oder ein Wunsch dann auch an dem äh wirklich an dem Teleskop zu arbeiten,
ist er doch so, dass der typische Forscher ja eigentlich fast nie ein richtiges Teleskop sieht. Der sitzt einfach in seinem Büro, an seiner Universität, an seinem Institut,
äh vor dem Computer oder wertet halt,
aus, schreibt seine Publikationen oder wenn er theoretisch ist, macht halt Simulationen und sonstige Berechnungen, er hat nichts was mit Beobachtungen zu tun.
Mich haben eben auch äh Beobachtungen an sich schon sehr interessiert an der Stelle können wir vielleicht auch mal erwähnen, dass sich ähm,
nicht nur beruflich Astronom bin, sondern äh Astronomie eben für mich auch ein Hobby ist. So was schon seit ich ungefähr neun oder zehn Jahre alt war.
Also mein Teleskop im Kinderzimmer.
Ja, nicht nur dort, sondern auch aufm Balkon bei meinen Eltern, wo ich dann in mancher klaren Nacht dann natürlich auch selber,
beobachtet habe und dann ist eben mit der Zeit so auch der Wunsch in mir gereift gewesen, das dann wirklich auch als Beruf zu machen dann, ja, auch nachdem ich also ich muss zu einer Zeit gewesen sein, wo ich ungefähr zehn oder 11 Jahre alt war.
Zu der Zeit habe ich mich damals schon so weiß nicht, so zwei oder drei Jahre eben schon für Astronomie interessiert gehabt und dann eben auch als Interesse da mal im Fernsehen eine eine Fernsehserie gesehen in der deutschen Übersetzung äh die Sterngucker geheißen hat,
die eben über über richtige Berufsastronomen äh gegangen ist äh,
wird ja um den großen Teleskopen auf der Welt beobachten
Auch mit Radioteleskopen und dann da ihre äh ihre Forschung machen und das hat mich eben so fasziniert. Damals habe ich gesagt, wow, also das möchte ich auch mal machen, wenn ich groß bin und ja.
Gar nicht. Sterngucker zwischen Himmel und Erde. Aha. Okay.
Eine Fernsehserie aus dem Ende der achtziger Jahre, ja. Glaube ich, ja.
Gibt's auch noch im Netz. Kann man sich.
Mhm. Wir waren glaube ich vier Episoden oder so.
Mhm. Okay, kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Und dann wo wo bist du denn hin ausgeflogen nach dem du dein Studium beendet hattest? Wo hast du denn deine Doktorarbeit gemacht.
So schnell ist das noch net gegangen, ja. Ähm,
Aus Passau, Niederbayern und bin dann eben äh äh nach München zum Studium gegangen,
Physik studiert. Habe dann im letzten Jahr meine Diplomarbeit äh bei der ISO in Gaiching,
gemacht im mit äh Daten von äh einem von den Werbe und ähm danach hat's mich äh zur Promotion nach Kopenhagen verschlagen.
Und äh ein Institut dort, das sich äh Dark Cosmology Center genannt hat.
Deswegen genannt hat, weil das äh das war so eine Art Exzellenzinitiative, die zehn Jahre gelaufen ist und das äh heute nicht mehr gibt.
Dortigen äh Nils angesiedelt, das war sehr die Physikfakultät von der Universität in Kopenhagen ist. Die ist ja sehr bekannt.
Ja wie auch Nils Bohr.
Genau.
Und dann bist du daran aber nicht geblieben.
Genau, das ist aber ein ähm war natürlich eine wichtige Station in äh in meiner Laufbahn äh und nicht zuletzt auch deswegen wichtig zu erwähnen äh,
weil dort auch der Schlüssel, darin liegt, wie ich dann am Ende eben über äh über diesen Umweg dann auf La Palma gelandet bin, ja. Auf dem Observatorium hier auf La Palma äh gibt's eine Teleskope von
verschiedenen Ländern, für verschiedenen Institutionen. Ja, wir werden später noch übers sprechen, das ist ein spanisches Teleskop ist.
Nicht das einzige.
Und auch auch nicht das Erste, das Ganze ähm observatorium ist ja schon Ende der,
Jahre geplant worden dann im Lauf der achtziger Jahre sind ja dann
die ersten Teleskope angekommen. Ja, die ersten waren äh sogar die Briten, die dann das Eisenteleskop äh installiert haben damals.
Dann gibt's zum Beispiel das teleskope-nationale Galileo, das von Italien betrieben wird.
Und dann geht's eben unter anderem auch äh das sogenannte Nordic Optikal Teleskop.
Das äh wie der Name schon äh verrät von den nordischen Ländern betrieben wird. Also Dänemark nur wegen Schweden, Finnland und Island.
Und dort arbeiten eben neben Festangestellt
Astronomen auch immer einige Doktoranden aus den nordischen Ländern mit, die dann da so als ein Jahr kommen und dann eben auch so äh
während sie an ihrer Doktorarbeit weitermachen, dann äh auch äh quasi als am an dem Teleskop dann mitarbeiten, da quasi schon Erfahrung sammeln können für ein Jahr.
Und nachdem ich äh Beobachtung eben schon immer sehr interessiert haben, war's für mich eben auch äh,
auch ein Ziel, das äh das auch zu machen, also habe ich mich an einem bestimmten Punkt in meiner Doktorarbeit dann darauf beworben, bin danach genommen worden
Und äh bin dann ja es ist jetzt ziemlich genau zehn Jahre her damals im Frühjahr 212 dann da eben für diese ja Studentship wie sich das nennt dann da nach La Palma gezogen um dann dafür ja dann haben noch da mitzuarbeiten,
Aus dem Jahr sind dann insgesamt ungefähr zwei Jahre geworden dann. Bis 2tausend014, in der Zwischenzeit war ich danach mit meiner Doktorarbeit fertig. Also da war ich dann es war dann Ende 2tausenddreizehn, ja. Und.
Gut, danach habe ich natürlich dann eine Stelle gesucht,
Und normalerweise,
sucht man ja nach dem nach der Doktorarbeit dann eine sogenannte Postdruckstelle,
Das Typische ist ja, dass man dann so zwei oder drei Jahre auf einer Postdruckstelle sitzt. Das ist so die typische Dauer von so einem Postdruck. Und dann sich den nächsten suchen muss wieder.
Vielleicht irgendwann mal, wenn man Glück hat, dann eine feste Stelle hat oder eine Professur oder so.
Nachdem ich sehr gern beobachten gehe, mit das sehr interessiert da natürlich auch äh dank der Erfahrung am Norden natürlich auch noch mehr Erfahrung gesammelt habe. Äh.
Was natürlich schon auch einer meiner Wünsche sozusagen äh dann auch äh danach eben als Support des und im Observatorium und irgendeinem Teleskop zu arbeiten, ja?
Ist
eben aber auch auf andere Post,
also es war eigentlich zu dem Zeitpunkt, was äh für mich eigentlich äh offen, wo ich dann am Ende landen würde. Es wäre vielleicht ein guter Moment, wo ich auch erklären könnte, ähm,
beides so seine Vor- und Nachteile hätte, ja. Ähm einerseits.
Was ein quasi ein Traum von mir wirklich äh an dem Teleskop äh zu arbeiten,
Andererseits hat die Arbeit als auch den Nachteil, dass man dann wenig Zeit hat für eigene Forschungen, für eigene Wissenschaft und das ist eben deswegen so ein großer Nachteil, weil,
Das Einzige, was zählt
in dem System wie Wissenschaft, wie die Wissenschaft so funktioniert, ist eben wie viel man publiziert, wie vielleicht eine Forschung man macht, wie viel man publiziert, ja. Ich habe daraufhin geschaut, diesen Ausdruck Publisher Paris. Also entweder du publizierst oder du gehst unter.
Das ist natürlich so, wenn man als Support des Teleskop arbeitet und dann eben naturgemäß wenig Zeit zum Publizieren hat äh für eigene Forschung.
Dann auch in den Verträgen steht's ja danach drin, dass man so 30 Prozent für eigene Forschung hat oder vielleicht wenn's hochkommt, 50 Prozent und das ist natürlich ganz klar, dass man dann nicht so viel publiziert,
Damit ist man dann natürlich im Wettbewerb mit allen anderen dann quasi ja raus.
Aber die anderen Wissenschaftler, die brauchen ja auch Unterstützung sozusagen.
Genau, das heißt also ähm von daher wär's für mich äh auch interessant gewesen eben quasi eine reine Forschungsstelle zu haben, auch wenn das dann natürlich bedeutet hätte, dass ich dann net so viel mit Teleskopen zu tun gehabt hätte. Also für mich war das irgendwie damals zu hoffen
aber ja du weißt ja um zwei wegzuwähren, du weißt ja schon, wie's dann bei mir ausgegangen ist, ja.
Genau, du bist ja äh habe ich ja schon auch erwähnt. Äh hier ist quasi hier als Support Astronau. Das heißt, du hast hier eine eine so eine Funktion, in der du quasi anderen Wissenschaftlern zuarbeitest und dafür sorgst, dass halt der gesamte Betrieb, also nicht alleine, aber halt äh ein Teil äh äh des Systems hier
sozusagen dafür sorgst, dass ja die Zielesgruppe auch tatsächlich funktionieren, das Richtige tun äh und dass all die ganzen beantragt
ähm Beobachtungszeiten dann auch tatsächlich genauso durchgeführt werden. Das ist alles irgendwie funktioniert, dass Probleme behoben werden et cetera. So oder so hast du ja auch
damit
eine wie soll ich sagen, eine sehr äh intime Beziehung zu diesem äh Teleskop. Kennst du's äh sehr gut sozusagen,
auch auf einer technischen Ebene. Man merkt das auch, wenn man mit anderen Wissenschaftlern äh spricht, die Teleskope benutzen
Dann wiederum nicht so viel darüber wissen, so wie das da eigentlich wirklich äh abgeht, weil die interessiert ja dann einfach nur so äh die Daten, machen sich aber über solche Sachen
nicht so die Gedanken. Genau und deswegen wollte ich ja genau diese Perspektive auch nochmal beleuchten,
Also wir haben's schon äh erwähnt, dieser äh Stand heute hier in äh in La Palma. Ähm also das Observatorium äh Rocke
Muchachos.
Genau. Das ist hier ganz weit oben. Ähm ich weiß gar nicht, also heißt der Berg heißt so, ne?
Ja wortwörtlich übersetzt Berg der Burschen.
Ja genau, der Burschenberg das ist hier so die äh höchste Erhebung auf der Insel.
Nicht da, wo jetzt der äh ausgebrochen ist. Das ist sozusagen so die der als das andere Bergmassiv im Süden, sondern halt im Norden, war aber auch definitiv mal ein Vulkan. Das merkt man äh sofort und oben so äh äh
da so steht, könnte man einen hervorragenden Ausblick haben. Ich war gestern da. Ähm,
Der Ausblick war nicht ganz so großartig, weil alles vor allem Wolken gehöhlt. Das äh ist hier nicht immer so. Ich weiß, aber ähm da hat sich so ein bisschen Pech, aber es war trotzdem ganz beeindruckend, da oben zu
stehen und dort sind wie viele Teleskope insgesamt untergebracht. Wieviel sind das äh derzeit ungefähr.
Selber mal nachts. Ich weiß nicht, es sind auch viele viele kleine dabei von Superwurst, also für eben Versuche nach Xo Planeten sind. Also da weiß ich selber nicht auswendig.
Aber so zehn oder so was in der Größe.
Von den Großen, also die von einigen Metern Durchmesser, können wir ja selber durchzählen, kannte, kann. Liverpoolitelles Cop.
Sechs einigermaßen großen Teleskopen sozusagen und dann noch vielen kleineren ja. Gibt auch äh einen Sonnenteleskopter.
Genau, das ist also quasi so ein Teleskop äh Zoo, aber du bist jetzt nur spezifisch fürs GTC zuständig.
Genau, äh man kann sich das ja so vorstellen, dass jedes äh Teleskop quasi ein eigenes Unternehmen ist. Das also von äh von dem Konsortium aus den Mitgliedsländern betrieben wird, ja.
Mhm,
Und das GTC wird dann vom IAC, also von dem Instituto der Astrophysico de Canarias, von dem ich hier schon berichtet habe, äh quasi mit äh administriert und das sozusagen deine Organisation an der Stelle, ne?
Ja
Warum redet man über das GTC, ist es schon ein besonderes Teleskop,
Ich habe so den Eindruck, das wissen auch irgendwie gar nicht so viele. Es ist nämlich äh nicht weniger als das größte,
optische Teleskop, was derzeit einfach im Betrieb ist auf der Welt,
gibt noch ein paar andere, die sind fast so groß, aber halt nicht größer.
Groß im Bezug auf den Spiegel
Das ist ja im Wesentlichen bei den Teleskopen der unterscheidende Faktor. Man hat hier in etwa einen Durchmesser von 10,4 Meter und das ist doch schon,
ganz schön groß. So und das äh wenn man so davor steht, kann ich berichten. Ich war ja gestern drin
schon ziemlicher Apparat, weil das muss ja dann auch irgendwie eingefasst sein, sprich die ganze Kuppel der das gesamte äh Gebäude, das hat schon eine ordentliche Aus
Dehnung und das ähm GTC ist halt ja auch vor allem besonders, weil es ja auch,
Man würde jetzt erwarten so, ah okay, Größe ist optisches Teleskop und so, das ist bestimmt eine super internationale Geschichte. Aber es ist ja eigentlich
primär wirklich von Spanien selbst finanzierten vorangetrieben worden. Gibt natürlich ein paar Kooperationen, EU-Förderung und sowas, aber ist schon eine sehr nationale Geschichte, oder?
Ja stimmt, es in der Tat vielleicht bissel überraschend, ja, wenn man mal das mit der ESO vergleicht, der hat sicher vielen Zuhörern ein Begriff ist, der quasi ein Zusammenschluss aus ähm
mindestens 15europäischen Ländern ist. Mitgliedsländern ist ähm im Vergleich dazu.
Gerade erwähnt, dass das Nordic Opel Teleskop von den fünf nordischen Ländern betrieben sind.
Für sich auch eigentlich relativ kleine Länder sind,
und Kante kann ist eben 90 Prozent Spanien, 5 Prozent Mexiko.
Und dann noch die University of Florida.
Und ähm seit ein paar Jahren haben wir jetzt dann nach China es neues Mitglied.
Und ja, aber es ist insgesamt ist in der Tat eine relativ kleine Community.
Aber ein großes Teleskop. Man kann auch gleich sagen,
Man weiß auch jetzt schon, das wird nicht lange halten. Größere Teleskope sind äh geplant, beziehungsweise auch schon äh im Bau, auf Hawaii soll ja mal ein thirty-Mieter Teleskop des TMT entstehen, aber ich glaube, das,
noch nicht so schnell voran, wie sie's gerne hätten das Projekt.
Ja es äh ich glaube, es sollte ja ursprünglich mal im Jahr 2018 die Entscheidung fallen, wo's dann am Ende konstruiert wird.
Mhm. Das ist noch nicht.
Es war ja klar, ist natürlich Hawaii nicht zuletzt, weil's natürlich ein amerikanisches Konzert umgeführt ist. Äh von den Amerikanern angeführt wird. Ähm,
und der Mann okay auf Hawaii ist ja im Prinzip der beste Standort für Astronomie auf der Nordhalbkugel der Erde.
Äh aus dem ganz einfachen Grund, weil er einfach äh mit seinen 4.200 Metern Höhe eben doch deutlich höher ist als hier. Zum Beispiel mit seinen 2400 Metern, ja.
Aber das dauert noch. Und was aber schon im äh Bau ist, ist das ELT, das Extremlila large Teleskop,
toller Name von der ESO halt äh und das wird natürlich dann äh alle Rekorde äh sprengen und dann wird auch erstmal eine ganze Weile lang nichts größer sein als das.
Ja, das wird dann eben auch in Chile gebaut. Wobei aber auch La Palma als alternativer Standort mal im Gespräch war,
aber am Ende ist es ja aber am Ende ist es dann natürlich äh in gebaut und wo dann natürlich auch die anderen Esotereskope sind, wo's ja schon die ganze Infrastruktur haben, ja ähm wo auch äh Alma steht, das ist große Area on äh Radioteleskopen,
genauer gesagt zu Millimeterteleskopen und eben damit man die quasi äh.
Da so eine Art ähm Symbiose kriegt, ja? Wenn
dass man dann die Objekte der Südhalbkugel dann am Südhimmel dann eben mit beiden mit beiden beobachten kann, sowohl mit einem so einem riesengroßen optischen Teleskop, weil sie immer danach mit so einem Radioteleskopen beziehungsweise Submillimeter.
Ja also schauen wir uns doch mal an äh wie dieses Teleskop eigentlich aufgebaut ist, wenn ein Standort haben wir ja jetzt schon was gesagt. War so ein bisschen übers Wetter ein bisschen überrascht. Also einerseits ja okay.
Da ist es nach wie vor Winter und im Winter gibt's immer wieder mal Schlechtwetterperioden, ja. Man merkt leider auch den Klimawandel sehr, dass sie das,
den gut, ich lebe jetzt doch schon die meiste Zeit äh des letzten Jahrzehnts hier und.
Es wird auch von vielen Menschen,
die hier leben und arbeiten auch von anderen Astronomen, also es ist jetzt nicht nur so eine so ein Eindruck äh von mir, so subjektive Eindrücke, können ja auch mal enttäuschen, aber es ist wirklich auch oder wenn man sich in der Statistiken einfach schaut, die ganzen Wetteraufzeichnungen so. Ähm,
extreme Wetterlagen nehmen die letzten Jahre oder letzten zehn Jahre ja doch durch
zu wenn es nicht nur so Schlechtwetterperioden wirst du es ja jetzt leider auch erleben hast,
bei deinem Besuch gestern, ne, dass das äh ganze Observatorium jetzt seit einer Woche mittlerweile in Nebel gehüllt ist.
Kann dann natürlich nicht beobachtet werden, ne.
Ja, da läuft nichts.
Ähm solche Schlechtwetter bei uns im Winter wesentlich häufiger als im äh als im Sommer.
Manche Winter sind eben äh schlechter als andere. Manchmal haben wir auch relativ viel Glück im Winter, aber manchmal eben auch viel Pech, wie im jetzigen Winter und für genau in so einer Zeit hast du uns jetzt besucht.
Ja, das äh das äh gibt's mal und ähm,
Darüber hinaus gibt's ja hier auf den Kanarischen Inseln noch ein äh Phänomen Wetterphänomen, das wir hier haben wie eben wegen der Nähe zur Sahara, dass dann eben der Sand und Staub aus der Sahara rüberkommt.
Das Phänomen das hat seinen eigenen Namen, nennt sich Kalima.
Kalima. Das ist ja auch so ein Weg äh ein großer Transportaustausch, dass der Sand von der Savara über den Atlantik komplett rüber in äh brasilianischen Dschungel et cetera Amazonas.
In Mitteleuropa, weil wenn man.
Bedenkt, dass das sogar nach Mitteleuropa kommt, kann man sich vorstellen, wie äh wie stark das ist, weil wir uns dann auf den wesentlichen 1hundert Kilometern von eben äh aus der Sahara dann auf den Kanarischen Inseln ankommt, ja.
Das heißt, es gibt so Phasen, so wetterbedingungen, wo dann extrem viel Staub ankommt und was müsst ihr da machen, da müsst ihr die Klappe zumachen.
Genau, also ähm.
So typischerweise sind eben diese Aerosole dann, wenn das so der Staub in der Luft so gemessen wird, so ein Mikrogramm pro Kubikmeter ist eigentlich so normal. Also es wäre schon sehr klare Luft und sehr klarer Himmel,
und eben seine Episoden von Kalima gibt es dann auch mal über fünfzig oder auch über 100 oder sogar mehrere unter den ganz extremen Fällen, ne? Und da ist dann natürlich ähm.
Der Himmel dann alles andere als klar. Also selbst wenn der Wolken los ist, das bedeutet natürlich auch mehr Extinktion.
Das ist quasi ähnlich wie wenn's äh wenn man leichte Wolken hätte, dass du dann quasi Licht wegnimmt.
Ach so. Also des Lichtes sozusagen, okay. Lichtvernichtung.
Genaueres so tun, ja? Es ist genau, das ist so ähnlich wie wenn man durch dünne Wolken beobachtet, ja? Da kann man auch noch beobachten und das wird halt vom Licht aus Objekte wird halt.
Also heißt es.
Verloren und das ist eben bei Kalima dann dann genauso.
Heißt es, dass es Probleme mit dem Sand eigentlich wirklich jetzt nur weniger Licht ist, aber nicht das jetzt der Sand äh ins Getriebe gerät sozusagen.
Leider auch, ja. Es ist eben ein sehr feiner Sonntag, der überall reinkommt. Deswegen ist jetzt dann bei großen Teleskopen irgendwie haben wir dann eben auch ein Limit
dann über 50 Mikrogramm pro Kubikmeter muss das dann geschlossen werden, ja. Bei kleineren Teleskopen ist es äh ein bisschen anders, die sind da nicht so streng, die beobachten noch selbst wenn Kalima hat von über hundert
extrem wird, muss dann auch wieder geschlossen werden, weil sie eben dann äh dieser ganz feine Staub, der kommt überall rein, zum Teil sogar bei geschlossener Kuppe.
Das ist in der tausend Probleme.
Jetzt hatten wir hier die letzten drei Monate kleinen Vulkanausbruch,
Der hat die äh die Insel hier hart mitgenommen, wirtschaftlich natürlich auch äh Belastung für für viele Leute. Wie hat sich das um euch ausgewirkt?
Ja, das war insofern eine sehr große Auswirkung, weil wir die drei Monate schlicht und ergreifend äh nicht nur, sondern alle Teleskope dann quasi den Betrieb einstellen mussten, ne.
Komplett. Die ganze Zeit über.
Der der Gipfel ist 2.400 Meter hoch und diese ganze Säule eben aus äh Gas und Staub, die der Vulkan heraus, die war so fünf oder sechs Kilometer hoch, wenn nicht sogar höher.
Also selbst auf auf dem Gipfel oben ist, dann hat die Vulkanasche runtergeregnet. Das ist das eine und zum anderen natürlich auch das sehr hohe Niveau an Schwefeldioxid.
Nicht nur gesundheitsschädlich ist, sondern eben auch äh der optische Flächen, so wie eben die Spiegel angreifen könnte.
Ah, okay. Also war das alles äh sehr late back. Es gab nicht viel zu tun in der Zeit.
Ja gut, wir haben natürlich weiter gearbeitet, ja? Man macht so seine Aufgaben im Büro oder wieder Zeit für eigene Wissenschaft und solche Sachen. Also aber eben die nächtlichen Beobachtungen haben immer eingestellt werden müssen, ja.
Okay, aber jetzt seitdem der äh Vulkan Ruhe gegeben hat, äh ist der Betrieb, wenn jetzt nicht gerade wieder äh stumm und äh Drang dort oben angesagt ist, dann äh wird jetzt wieder weiter gearbeitet.
Genauso Ende Dezember, seitdem auch dann die ganze Asche dann beseitigt worden ist, ja.
Gut, kommen wir doch mal auf äh die Struktur, also wie das äh Teleskop jetzt so in der Landschaft steht. Klar, so ein optisches äh Teleskop braucht eine Schutzhülle.
Kennt man's, diese typische
Kuppelbauten, wo man an einer Stelle so einen ähm Öffnungsschlitz äh hat, wo das Teleskop dann durchschauen kann. Aber es gibt ja sehr unterschiedliche Ansätze äh darin, wie das gebaut wird, was sich dann letztlich dreht.
Um irgendwo hinzuschauen richtig mitbekommen habe ist es so beim GTC sowohl die komplette
Aufhängung, wo der Spiegel drin hängt, der ganze Apparat kann sich natürlich irgendwie drehen und dann der obere Teil der
dreht sich auch. Also es gibt da so eine Ballustrade auf weiß nicht zehn Meter Höhe äh und ab dort dreht sich dann irgendwie alles äh wenn man das Teleskop entsprechend ausrichten möchte.
Ja das Teleskop selber ist ja eben auf so einem auf so einer extra rotierenden Plattform montiert quasi die vom Rest der Kuppel,
Isoliert ist, damit sie da keine Schwingungen und so übertragen.
Mhm.
Und ähm montiert jetzt das heißt es gibt eine äh und eine Höhenachse. Und ähm,
ist Teleskop selber kann sich äh dann eben auf dieser Plattform bewegen und die Kuppel eben mit dem Kuppel spielt Spalt wird dann eben separat äh nachgeführt.
Wie du schon grad erwähnt hast, äh so wie das äh aufgebaut ist, ist bei anderen Teleskopen äh ist das dann zum Teil eben nur ein Gebäude, wo sich alles äh gleichzeitig bewegt.
Dann auch bei kleineren Teleskopen wie jetzt im Eissaktiventeleskop ist zum Beispiel noch so, dass das in der Tat noch ein äh equatoryal montiertes Teleskop ist.
Dass ja viele Hobbysternen äh Gucker von den Amateurteleskopen kennen, der auch typischerweise quatroriale Montierungen haben.
Kannst du das mal erklären? Equatoriale Montierung und Azimut äh Orientierung, was.
Bei einer bei einer Equatoria Montierung wird eben eine Achse parallel zur Erdachse ausgerichtet.
Zum Nordpol und das hat dann eben den Vorteil dann eben um das Teleskop nachzuführen, also um der Bewegung der Stände zu folgen, heißt's dann, dass man eben zum Nachsehen des der guten Wirkung diese eine Achse bewegen muss.
Ist also äh insofern sehr praktisch.
Aber eben für sehr große Teleskope ist das eben nicht machbar, ja? Kann man sich vorstellen, dass dann wenn's so große Gewichte auf so einer schrägen Achse liegen würden, dass das äh schwierig bis unmöglich wäre und deswegen wären eben dann ganz große Teleskope dann eben
montiert. Das heißt, man soll also wirklich nur eine äh eine horizontale Aktie und eine vertikale Achse, ja. Eben auch Azimut und Höhe genannt, ja.
Also kann man das so sagen beliebig irgendwo hinzeigen lassen.
Genau, aber da muss man eben auch in beiden beiden Achsen nachführen, aber das ist ja heute Computersteuer kein großes Problem.
Ja, okay. In dieser großen Struktur, also mit Struktur meine ich jetzt quasi so einen.
So eine Art Käfig, in dem irgendwie alles äh eingefangen ist. Darin äh liegt dann dieser äh riesige Spiegel und muss sagen, wenn man so hört, zehn Meter vierzig.
Denkt man sich so ja okay what's the deal so zehn Meter vierzig, was ist schon zehn Meter vierzig, zehn Meter vierzig bin ich ein paar mit.
Sich mal eben gelaufen irgendwie, man
nimmt das nicht so richtig wahr, aber wenn man dann irgendwie so vor diesem Spiegel steht, ist das doch schon ein ziemlich äh fetter Apparat. Vor allem ist es ja nicht ein Spiegel, sondern der Spiegel ist ja aus mehreren Spiegeln zusammengesetzt.
Wie funktioniert das.
Ja
man sieht da eben, dass äh bei Teleskopen kann man wirklich äh mit Fug und Recht sagen, sei es der Hauptgrund, warum man einen Teleskop eigentlich so groß wie möglich haben möchte ist eben, dass du dann mehr Licht einsammeln, ne?
Wenn man sich diesen menschliche Auge ansieht zum Beispiel, ne? Man kann ja auch mitm äh bloßen Auge Objekte am Himmel sehen. Ja, die Probleme des menschlichen Auges oder so paar Millimeter Durchmesser, ja.
Maximal acht Millimeter, ja, wenn's hochkommt, ja? Und ähm mit einem Teleskop kann man natürlich mehr Licht einsammeln, ja.
Allein schon äh ein kleines Amateureskorp, ja, das vielleicht zehn oder 20 Zentimeter Durchmesser hat,
So zum Beispiel ist er dann jetzt schon deutlich größer als das menschliche Auge oder auch ein Fernglas, Feldstecher, ja
äh und sammelt dadurch ja schon mehr deutlich viel mehr Licht ein als das menschliche Auge, ja? Man darf in dem Zusammenhang auch nicht vergessen, dass ja die Lichtsammelfläche mit dem mit dem Quadrat des Durchmessers wächst,
Also zehnmal so viel Durchmesser heißt dann eben auch schon 1hundert Mal soviel Lichtsammelvermögen.
Und dementsprechend kann man natürlich wesentlich schwächere Objekte sehen damit.
Aber man kann also einen Spiegel nicht aus einem Stück fertigen und deswegen ist es äh unterteilt.
Genau, also der größten Teleskop, die aus einem einzelnen Spiegel bestehen, sind eben äh welche mit acht Meter Durchmesser. Wie eben die berühmten in Chile. Da machen 8,2 Meter Durchmesser und sind eben noch aus einem Monolithischen Spiegel.
Was aber extrem schwierig zu bauen ist, was weil denen dann richtig zu schleifen und korrekt hinzubekommen und einzustellen, das erfordert eine extreme Präzision und deswegen geht man jetzt bei den größeren Spiegeln dazu über, die aus Subspiegeln,
zusammenzubauen.
Genau, größere Spiele kommen, sondern eben nur eben aus einzelnen Segmenten dann zusammensetzen, ja.
Genauso wie im Übrigen jetzt das James Web äh Teleskop über das jetzt viel gesprochen worden ist, auch hier bei äh Raumzeit. Da ist natürlich ganz praktisch, weil dann kann man's halt auch gleich äh zusammenklappen, aber trotzdem um einfach eine bestimmte Größe hinzubekommen, scheint es ja ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Gut also mit ersten Teleskope, die eben segmentierten Spiegel dann gebaut worden sind, waren eben zum Beispiel die Teleskope auf Hawaii,
Damals ähm bei Installationen auf der neunziger Jahre eben die größten optischen Teleskope auf der Welt waren, ja. Mit 1,2 Metern Durchmesser und,
Natürlich solche segmentierten Spiegel gehabt aufgrund ihrer Größe und ähm,
wird dann das Ganze des geplant worden ist, war ja ursprünglich eigentlich auch ein acht Meter Teleskop geplant.
In mit einem monolithischen Spiegel so, dass wir allerdings alles noch relativ einfach, ja
Und aber dann äh ist eben im äh Lauf der Planungen ist man dann ziemlich schnell draufgekommen, wenn man so ne spiegelt dann auf äh den raufbringen will. Und du hast ja die Straße gesehen,
einen Besucher, wenn da wenn da sechsunddreißig Kilometer,
rauffährt und 200 Kurven, zum Teil sehr eng, ja. Ähm da war klar, dass das einfach ein unüberwindliches Problem wäre, da so einen acht Meter Spiegel da rauf zu transportieren.
Hubschrauber wäre vielleicht noch gegangen.
Gut, ich kenne jetzt nicht die Details, wie das damals bei den Planungen war und was da alles da so ähm in Betracht gezogen worden ist, aber am Ende ist man dann halt doch zu dem äh Schluss gekommen, dass das dann doch nicht gangbar war. Und das eben.
Dann der beste Weg äh war so ein großes Teleskop zu bauen, eben so einen segmentierten Spiegel zu machen und dann hat man halt die Idee gehabt, okay, wenn man den Sonnen sowieso äh segmentiert machen muss, dann kann man's auch gleich bissl größer machen und dann haben sie eben gesagt, okay die Gruppe haben 10,2 Meter Durchmesser
Ähm äh macht das heute noch ein kleines bissel größer, zehn, 4 Meter und haben damit das äh größte optische Teleskop auf der ganzen Welt.
Was natürlich rein wissenschaftliche Gründe hat, selbstverständlich. Da bin ich mir sicher. Ja, okay.
Gut, also man blickt auf 36 Hexer, Gunale
Teilspiegel, die halt eng beieinander sind, wenn man so davor steht, gerade wenn man so ein bisschen schräg guckt, dann wirkt das eben schnell auch wirklich so wie ein Spiegel diese kleinen äh Ritze dazwischen fallen kaum auf.
In der Mitte ist natürlich etwas freigehalten, weil das Licht, was ja von den Spiegeln aufgenommen wird erstmal wieder nach vorne äh geschickt wird zum Sekundärspiegel, der in dieser Halterung davor äh schwebt
genauso wie auch beim James Fips halt einfach diese diese Bau äh Weise, ich habe vorher nochmal nachgeschaut, die hat ja auch so einen auch so einen schönen Namen.
Ja, also der Strahlengang ist eigentlich so äh so wie bei einem Kassegrad Teleskop. Beziehungsweise dieser Typ äh heißt äh,
System das ist eine Spezialform des Kassigersystems wo eben der der Hauptspiegel statt äh parabolischen Form in der hyperpolitischen Form hat.
Aber das Grundprinzip ist das Gleiche wie beim Klassiker, dass man eben den den Hauptspiegel hinten im Teleskop
der dann den Licht zum Sekundärspiegel oben äh zurückwirft, der dann wiederum äh das Licht äh in den Fokus äh zurückwirft
der der dann eben hinter dem Hauptspiegel liegt und dann natürlich da eben so eine Lücke drin ist dann, ne?
Genau, damit das immer ein Loch und dann kommt dann sozusagen das nochmal äh weitergebündelte Licht äh durch, wobei es ja bei dem GTC jetzt so ist, dass äh schon auf dem Weg vorher,
äh dieser Lichtstrahl auch nochmal abgelenkt wird, weil es äh eine spezielle Positionierung der Instrumente äh.
Ja was du da ansprichst, ist eben äh dann der Nassmessfokus, ja. Was ich grad beschrieben habe, ist eben dieser typische Klassiker Fokus, da wo jemand dann auch ein Instrumente seiner Kamera dann montiert werden kann, ja? Ähm.
Das ist ja da auch so, also es gibt auch ein Instrument hinter dem Spiegel, aber man hat auch noch die Möglichkeit vorne eins unterzubringen. Zwei sogar.
Genau oder sogar noch mehr. Also das ist also bei vielen, also ich habe ja vorher auch äh zum Beispiel den Kopf angesprochen, da ist das auch so. Die haben ein Instrument im Kassegraph Fokus montiert und dann noch zwei weitere in den zwei nassmes Foki.
Das heißt, auf dem Weg vom Zweit äh Spiegel wieder äh auf die Mitte äh des großen Spiegels zurück, wird es auch quasi auf halbem Wege noch mal abgefangen, also.
Genau, also entweder man benutzt den Kassegraf Fokus und äh also der ist dann hinten hinterm Teleskop, hinter mir direkt hinterm Haupt,
während der Nasmis Foki eben dann unten auf der Seite sind. Das heißt, da wird dann das Licht nicht
das äh Loch im Hauptspiegel gelenkt, sondern durch einen äh davorliegenden im angebrachten äh dritten Spiegel
dann äh auf die Seite ungelenkt zum äh zum ja davor hat man dann zwei wie ich erwähnt habe.
Das heißt also entweder man stellt den Spiegel so ein, dass er
dass er das Licht dann zu dem einen Fokus äh weiterleitet oder man dreht das ganze Blend an, damit's dann zu dem anderen Fokus geleitet wird. Das heißt also, je nachdem, mit welchem Instrument man beobachten will, muss man dann einfach nur über den äh über diesen Spiegel dann.
Einfach einstellen, was man haben will sozusagen. Kein Spiegel, das
einfach durch die Mitte oder halt links und rechts äh abgelenkt. Das heißt, auf dieser ganzen Konstruktion, wo halt der Spiegel gehalten wird und natürlich auch der
äh Sekundärspiegel vorne äh dran ist, hat man hinter dem Spiegel ein dickes Instrument und links und rechts davon auch nochmal zwei große äh Kaskaden mit äh allerlei äh Gerät und das sind dann eben die eigentlichen,
Ja, das sind die eigentlichen Teleskope, das ist sozusagen das, wo dann tatsächlich aus dem Licht auch wirklich erst ein Signal wird. So,
Ähm ja das ich denke sehr viel mehr muss man zum Aufbau auch gar nicht sagen. Ähm,
Natürlich interessant, was für Instrumente kommen jetzt hier zum,
Einsatz. Ich meine, wir sagen ja schon die ganze Zeit optisches Teleskop, das heißt, hier wird natürlich vor allem das sichtbare Licht aufgenommen, aber ich denke mal, ein gewisser Teil im Infrarotbereich dürfte dieses Teleskop auch noch bedienen.
Natürlich, also genau genommen ist eben genau bei optisch äh damit meint man eben das sichtbare Licht, aber da gehört natürlich dann auch noch der Infrarotbereich dazu, ja.
Der ist nur für uns nicht so sichtbar, aber für so einen Spiegel schon.
So das äh Nahinfrarot ist eigentlich, also wenn man von Infrarot,
merkt man eigentlich meistens so das Neuinfrarot, ja? Nur noch mal so zur Erinnerung, also sichtbares Licht oder so Wellenlängen so zwischen 400 und 700 Nanometer ungefähr und äh kürzere Wellenlängen wäre dann eben ultraviolett
und ähm bei längeren Willen, da kommt unser erstes
das ungefähr bis zu 2500 Nanometer geht, also 2,5 Mikronen,
danach schließt sich eben das mittlere Infrarot und das bis ungefähr 20 Mikrometer geht. Und das äh,
ist dann eben zu der Wellenlänge im Bereich der mit so einem Teleskop beobachtet werden kann, dann eben mit äh den verschiedenen Instrumenten und,
auch den Grund warum man eben an so einem Teleskop dann mehrere solcher Kameras, mehrere Instrumente hat. Zum Beispiel ein optisches oder hat man ein optisches Instrument eben für sichtbares Licht oder und eins für fürs Neuinfrarot.
Oder eins fürs mittlere Infrarot und ähm ähm abgesehen vom äh von unterschiedlichen Wellenlängebereichen äh ähm,
werden Instrumente auch für verschiedene Aufgaben eben ja,
konstruiert oder gebaut, ja? Man nimmt ja nicht nur Bilder auf in verschiedenen Filtern, sondern der wichtigste Art von Beobachtung in der Astronomie ist eigentlich die Spektoskopie.
Das heißt also typischerweise äh Auktion ist somit eben die Möglichkeit entweder Bilder aufzunehmen und auch Spektren.
Dann gibt's nur auch so spezielle Beobachtungs äh Moden äh wie zum Beispiel den wo man also Spektrum von mehreren Objekten gleichzeitig aufnehmen kann.
Da muss man auch noch unterscheiden, auch bei grad bei Spektorafen. So ein typisches Instrument, so ein Instrument äh,
Typischerweise eben Imaging äh und Spektoskopie mit relativ geringer Auflösung. Und dann gibt's eben auch Spektografen mit höherer Auflösung. Das werden also dann wieder X-Instrumente, ja.
Was man vorhin gar nicht erwähnt haben ist, wie jung das äh Projekt eigentlich noch ist, weil der Bau ist ja erst 2tausend8 abgeschlossen, also im Vergleich zu anderen Teleskopen ist das ja noch äh relativ frisch äh,
äh ach so bis 2018 gebaut worden, 209 wurde es dann äh erstmalig in Betrieb genommen und ähm ja also von daher liegt das alles noch gar nicht so lange äh zurück und,
was so an Instrumenten dort zum Einsatz kommt,
hat sich bereits schon mehrfach geändert und äh wird sich auch in der Zukunft noch äh ändern. Also es ist jetzt irgendwie kein fixes System, sondern da ist noch sehr viel in Betrieb und sehr viel in Planung. Welche äh Instrumente kommen denn
dort äh jetzt konkret zum Einsatz.
Ja, du hast ja gestern bei deinem Besuch äh oben das äh optische Instrument gesehen, das im Kassegraf Fokus montiert ist.
Instrument.
Mit dem Namen Osiris,
ähm ist wie gesagt äh Big mit dem man im sichtbaren Licht beobachtet, also Imaging, Spektoskopier, relativ niedrige Auflösung und auch die.
Was heißt denn relativ niedriger Auflös.
Genau, also bei äh der spektrale Auflösung, also quasi wie für.
Also du meinst, wie fein man es in in die Teilfri.
Äh spektakuläre Auflösung ist äh äh quasi so definiert, das ist äh,
Wellenlänge dividiert durch die seine Wellenlängen Unterschied, der eben noch aufgelöst werden kann,
wenn man zum Beispiel bei 500 Nanometern äh eben einen Nanometer auflösen kann, das wird dann eine Auflösung von fünfhundert, ja. Und eben bei Auflösungen von einigen hundert bis tausend oder zweitausend spricht man eben von ja, so niedriger Auflösung.
Und das ist jetzt hier der.
So ähm ja je nach Gebiet, da spricht man dann vielleicht bei Auflösen inzwischen 5tausend und 10tausend von mittleren Auflösungen, dann bis 50.000 oder sogar 100.000 von von hohen oder sehr hohen Auflösungen, ne.
Ein technischer Kompromiss, also es ist nicht so, dass man's nicht hätte feiner bauen können, aber man sagt einfach so in dem Instrument reicht diese Auflösung, wir haben eine andere Zielsetzung mit diesem.
Ja natürlich das so das ja das Typische, was so ähm.
Die meisten Beobachtungen so gebraucht wird, ist es natürlich so, je höher die Auflösung ist, desto heller müssen die Objekte eigentlich sein.
Die man beobachten kann. Also mit niedriger Auflösung äh kann man auch Spektren von äh ziemlich schwachen Objekten aufnehmen. Aber die gleichen Objekte dann mit sehr hoher Auflösung zu beobachten ist
dann äh schwierig bist unmöglich oder wird einfach viel zu viel Zeit in Anspruch nehmen, ja.
Mal definieren als äh wenn man sich Sterne in unserem in unserer Galaxie in der Milchstraße anschaut, dann passt das schon, aber so für Fangaxin äh könnte man dann auf was anderes ausweichen.
Genau, da kommt dann auch auf der wissenschaftliche Fragestellung an, den wir da mit für für viele Dinge erreicht und eine niedrige Auflösung. Aber eben für viele spitze spezielle Dinge, ähm sei es per Planeten oder bei genauen Studien von einzelnen Sternen, da da wo man dann wirklich eine sehr hohe, spektrale Auflösung braucht
dann hat man dann immer auch die entsprechenden Instrumente dafür. Die Objekte sind dann auch hell genug, beziehungsweise man braucht dann auch einen Teleskop-Diskos genug ist dafür, ja.
Hat dann natürlich so ein großes Teleskop dann äh
den Vorteil gegenüber kleineren, dass man dann eben äh Spektrum mit höherer Auflösung aufnehmen kann, wo man dann mit einem kleineren Teleskop nur niedrigere Auflösung spektale Auflösung eben,
möglich ist.
Mhm. Okay, das ist also das äh Instrument, was was gibt's noch? Was äh was hängt denn da links und rechts noch dran?
Genau, dann haben wir noch ein äh neue Infrarotinstrument mit dem Namen Emir.
Das eben äh sowohl Imaging als auch Spektoskopie im äh im nahen Infrarot machen kann, also so zwischen äh einem Mikro und zweieinhalb Mikronähr äh Wellenlänge.
Und äh auch Kopie machen kann, also Spektrum von bis zu 50 Objekten gleichzeitig aufnehmen kann.
Ah, okay.
Und äh weiß net, ob ich das grad erwähnt habe und ähm Osiris kann ja auch meist die Aufstiegsspektoskopie machen, also wo man dann auch äh mit einer mit einer Maske dann äh Spektren von äh einigen Dutzend Objekten gleichzeitig aufnehmen kann.
Was ganz praktisch ist, wenn man jetzt wirklich mehrere gleichzeitig im selben Bereich äh auswerten und beobachten möchte, dann muss man halt nicht nochmal hin und noch mehr Zeit verbrauchen, sondern kann das quasi in einem Go machen.
Genau, das ist also dann so das typische Gesichtsfeld von so einem Instrument äh sind nur so einige Bogenminuten, ja.
Relativ kleines äh Feld eigentlich, ja? Ähm,
habe ich immer so den Eindruck, dass Menschen meinen, äh mit dem großen Teleskop könnte man einen großen Bereich am Himmel sehen, das ist natürlich nichts, ist eher fast im Gegenteil so. Je größer, desto kleiner wird dann das äh Gesichtsfeld eigentlich.
Und ähm typisches Gesichtsfeld von so den Instrumenten,
in dem Bereich von einigen Bogenminuten, ja. Zum Vergleich, äh sowohl Sonne als auch Mond haben wir ja am Himmel einen scheinbaren Durchmesser von ungefähr 30 Bogenminuten, also in einem halben Grad. Also den Ausschnitt am Himmel
da ähm auf einmal beobachten kann, ist also quasi ein kleiner Ausschnitt
äh von Mond oder Sonne am Himmel von der Größe, ja? Ist ja doch sehr kleiner Ausschnitte.
Aber dafür halt sehr genau.
Aber wenn man dann eben äh mehrere Objekte hat in in diesem,
einen Gesichtsfeld und dann eben die Möglichkeit hat ähm von mehreren äh Objekten sprechen dann gleichzeitig aufzunehmen.
Okay, also sowohl als auch äh Emir können äh äh das und äh E-Mail ist halt dann auf Infrarot optimiert. Hat das dann eine hohe Auflösung im im Sinne.
Hat auch äh Spektoskopie mit eher niedriger Auflösung.
Ah okay, gut. Aber dafür Infrarot. Also wird das dann zum Beispiel für exoplaneten auch schon eingesetzt.
Ja also auch besonders wird für für Planeten,
Planeten zu entdecken beziehungsweise zu äh zu bestätigen. Da braucht man keine so großen Teleskope. Aber wo immer
so ein großes Teleskop wie sehr interessant ist, ist eben um dann zum Beispiel transvisionsspektoskopie von exoplaneten zu machen und mehr über die Atmosphären zu erfahren.
Da ist dann so ein äh großes Teleskop mit äh Vermögen dann doch von Vorteile.
So, jetzt haben wir zwei Instrumente schon besprochen, aber hängt aber noch ein Drittes.
Genau, ja, seit äh vier oder fünf Jahren haben wir auch ein äh Instrument mit dem Namen Megara. Das ist auch ein Instrument, das im äh optischen Bereich äh beobachtet.
Und dessen äh Spezialität ist äh die sogenannte Kopie. Ähm,
Bei diesem Beobachtungsmodus wird äh,
eben äh von dem ja vergleichsweise kleinen Gesichtsfeld von so einigen Bogensekunden äh Durchmesser beziehungsweise Größe eben dann ein Spektrum aufgenommen, wo man dann quasi von jedem Punkt ähm
in diesem äh Gesichtsfeld dann ein Spektrum aufnimmt.
Also komplette Ma.
Da hat man dann äh ja so ähnlich äh so ähnlich wie in der Matrix. Also wenn man so ein bissel so ein äh ausgedientes Objekt hat, dann kriegt man quasi von,
Nimmt man quasi nicht nur einen ein Spektrum von dem ganzen Objekt auf, weil normalerweise sollte an der Stelle vielleicht erwähnen, normalerweise hat man ja bei der Spektoskopie hat man ja so einen Spalt, ja,
Auf englisch genannt, äh der das äh Licht von einem Objekt ähm quasi herausnimmt und den Rest des Gesichtsfeld verdeck,
und dahinter hat man ja dann das, was äh Element, das ist ein sogenanntes ja, äh das dann das äh Spektrum erzeugt, ja und ähm die Breite dieses,
bestimmt und auch mit der Auflösung ja, je schmaler der Spalt, desto höher die Auflösung, ja? Das da hat man auch wieder so diese Abwägung da. Ja, man kann äh entweder mit bissel weniger Auflösung äh,
Auflösung beobachten, indem man im äh breiteren Spalt nimmt. Da kriegt man dann mehr Licht durch. Äh auch das grad äh schlecht ist dann auch gut, dass man trotzdem äh mehr Licht durchkriegt, äh wenn man eine höhere Auflösung braucht, kann man dann den äh schmaleren äh,
äh kriege dann aber auch weniger Licht durch. Ja, hat man dann den sogenannten dass da bissel Licht verloren geht, also das sind dann so diese Abwägungen, die man da machen,
danach eine Rolle spielen, ja.
Hörern wird das äh wird es klar sein, dass sie ein Spektroskopie halt äh extrem äh wichtig ist bei der Beobachtung äh von allem Möglichen. Ähm Universum würde da jetzt sozusagen perfektes Sonnenlicht kommen, da hätte man halt einen Regenbogen, aber so schaut man eben auf äh bestimmte Sterne und kann halt dann anhand
der Teile, wo es eben heller ist, äh eben in diesem Spektrum Rückschlüsse darauf führen, woraus dieser Stern besteht oder was auch immer, ob man gerade anschaut.
Eben. Man sieht dann der Absorptionslinien oder auch Emmissionslinien. Da ist eben der ganzen Spektralinien, die einem verschiedenste Informationen geben, eben über chemische Zusammensetzung, Elementhäufigkeit
auch Geschwindigkeiten, Eigenbewegungen, ja über einen Dopplereffekt beziehungsweise dann auch bei äh sehr weit entfernten Objekten, also wo ich gerade äh gesprochen habe, bei sehr hoher Rotverschiebung, wo sich's ja dann um die kosmologische Rotverschiebung handelt, die durch Expansion des Universums geschieht, die dann eben auch quasi
Indikator für die Entfernung ist, beziehungsweise die Zeit, die man dann zurückschaut, ja.
Auch ein Grund warum es äh wichtig ist nicht nur im Optischen sondern auch im Infrarot zu beobachten.
Mein ein äh Grund ist natürlich, dass Objekte nicht nicht nur im sichtbaren Licht imitieren, sondern auch im Infrarot, um halt dadurch schon einen weiteren äh über größeren Überblick über über die Objekte kriegt, wenn man nicht nur das sichtbare Licht.
Und durchaus Staubeur durchschauen.
Infrarot äh wir sind zu Radiowellen und eben bei hoher Verschiebung ist es dann äh eben so, dass äh,
das Licht, das eigentlich ja sichtbares Licht dann durch die so stark verschoben wird, dass es dann in sinnfreirot verschoben wird. Das heißt also, mit Infrarotbeobachtungen beobachten wir eben bei Rubrik mit hoher Europaschildmögen eben das Licht, das ursprünglich eigentlich sichtbares Licht war, ja?
Zurückliegt und schon so sehr verzerrt wurde durch das expandierende Universum.
Verschoben wurde.
Mhm. Okay. Das ist sozusagen die aktuelle Bestückung äh des GTC.
Genau, ja. Äh vor einigen Jahren hatten wir auch ein Instrument äh fürs mittlere Infrarot, ja. Sogar ziemlich vom Anfang äh an.
Äh mit dem Namen
Instrument war das eben im mittleren Fred beobachten konnte, also zwischen bei Wellingen, zwischen 5 Millionen und zwanzig Mikron.
Das ist aber eben äh grad bei so einem großen Teleskop interessant, weil beim im mittleren Infrarot äh ist es so, dass noch mehr als in Nor Infrarot ist äh Himmelshintergrund im.
Sehr hell, ja. Das ist schon äh mein großer Unterschied zwischen Beobachtungen und optischen und dem Infrarot. Dass er im optischen, wenn man so mitm bloßen Auge zum Himmel schaut, schaut er da nachts, zumindest in der mordlosen Nacht der doch ziemlich schwarz aus, ja?
Zwar nicht auch der dunkelste Nachthimmel leuchtet, sogar im optischen Bereich.
Eigentlich noch relativ schwach. Das im Infrarot ist das wesentlich anders. Da ist der Himmelshintergrund äh von der Atmosphäre her wesentlich heller als im Optischen, ja. Also Beobachtungen im Neuen Frau Roth schon äh schwieriger macht als im Optischen.
Gerade deswegen sind auch äh so große Teleskope wichtig auch für Beobachtungen im äh im Infrarotbereich und besonders wenn's dann eben um Objekte bei hoher Rotweich übergeht, sie entfernt die Objekte sondern eben nur sehr wenig Licht ankommt.
Und im mittleren Infrarot ist diese Problem dann eben nochmal verschärft, da ist nochmal heller und da macht man das ist dann eben wirklich nur,
sinnvoll mit wirklich sehr großen Teleskopen. Also hier von eben so acht oder zehn Metern Durchmesser, wie eben die VITs oder eben auch das Ganze kann.
Da spielen die Dinger dann sozusagen ihre Vorteile voll aus.
Irgendwo hatte ich gesehen, dass da noch so eine ganze Timeline mal geplant ist, noch weitere Instrumente äh einzubauen. Also sind das dann sozusagen würden die dann,
in irgendeiner Form so montiert werden, dass man die so im Betrieb austauschen äh kann gegen andere oder sind das dann quasi schon die.
Wer monkante kann noch äh mehr Pokalstationen als die drei, die wir,
erwähnt haben, also den Klassiker Fokus, die zwei Nasmis und dann gibt's noch äh vier weitere Stationen
der nennt sich dann Volldet Kassegra, der also in diesem Ring außenrum, den sie gestern da bei dem Besuch gesehen hast dann. Äh da wurde dann noch weitere.
Fokaltstationen äh eben gibt, da haben insgesamt vier davon noch. In einem ist äh Instrument äh Megawa äh montiert. Äh zur Zeit, also insgesamt haben wir dadurch dann quasi Platz für sieben Instrumente.
Ah, okay
die müssen halt alle irgendwie erstmal gebaut werden, aber jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, okay, 7 Instrumente, jetzt deckt man mit diesen Dreien, die man jetzt schon hat, schon äh bestimmte Bereiche ab, was äh was kann jetzt noch kommen, also mehr Auflösung, toller,
schöner, heller weiter.
Ich habe ja schon erwähnt, äh der Unterschied zwischen Niederrespektaler Auflösung und hoher, spektakulärer Auflösung. Also wenn man jetzt die ganzen Instrumente nochmal durchgehen Rossiri ist und wie gesagt, beobachte ich im optischen Bereich, eben Imaging und spektoskopie war relativ niedriger Auslösung. Auflösung.
Dann Emira eigentlich das Gleiche im äh im Neuinfrarot. Dann gibt's noch äh haben wir bislang noch gar nicht erwähnt, einen Spektographen mit äh hoher Auflösung, ja.
Äh nimmt eben optische Spektren auf bei äh ziemlich hoher Auflösung. Ungefähr 20tausend.
Spektakuläre Auflösung.
Das bezieht sich jetzt auf welche Einheit.
Auflösung ist eigentlich eine dimensionslose Zahl, ist eigentlich äh von der Wellenlänge zur Wellenlänge, die gerade noch aufgelöst werden kann. Also spektakuläre Auflösung ist in der Tat eine dimensionslose Zahl,
Und ähm das ist ein Instrument, das äh über Glasfaser ähm,
Es liegt zugeführt kriegt, die eben äh das eben mit Osiris gekoppelt ist und wie Osiris noch im Nassmessfokus äh montiert war, war das eben auf der gleichen Plattform daneben installiert.
Ja, mit Glasfaser heißt man leitet sozusagen das Licht an der Stelle, wo es erstmal ankommt äh schiebt man quasi so eine Glasfaser rein und dann geht es durch die Glasfaser zum.
Also ein Instrument, das nicht direkt in einer Pokalstation am Teleskop montiert ist, sondern eben mit bissel Abstand dann eigener so ein eigener Kasten ist sozusagen, der dann sich auch nicht mit dem Teleskop mit,
auch wichtig bei hoher Auflösung und dann eben über Gasfaser dann sozusagen gefüttert wird, ja,
Aber jetzt, wo eben Osiris äh vom Nasmis Fokus in den Kassegraf Fokus verlegt worden ist, äh ist,
Das ist mit im Moment äh eben nicht mehr in Betrieb. Also das wäre wieder so ein Beispiel von dem Instrument, das mal im Betrieb war, zurzeit wieder nicht. Also das ganze Instrumentarium wie gesagt verändert sich dann im Laufe der Jahre.
Mhm. Und was noch so andere, die dann geplant sind, was kann da kommen.
Genau, ich habe eben grad äh von dem Spektographen, von dem hochauflösenden Spektografen im optischen Bereich gesprochen,
in ein paar Monaten kriegen wir dann den Spektographen äh für den Infrarotbereich, fürs Neuinfrarot mit sehr hoher Auflösung.
Quasi die Verbesserung vom Emil darstellen würde.
Nicht direkt eine Verbesserung ist. Ist ja quasi es hat jedes äh Instrument und jedes äh jeder Beobachtungsmodus hat so seine Anwendungen, ja. Also,
Schon erwähnt, es gibt Anwendungen für Spektoskopie äh mit relativ niedriger Auflösung.
Anderer Schwerpunkt sozusagen.
Genau und eben äh deswegen hat man's dann eben auch ein extra Instrument eben auch für höhere Spektrale Auflösung.
Das ist auch so ein klingenden Namen.
Hat genau, das hat dann den Namen Meradas, ja.
Ist ein spanischer Name sozusagen da. Gut, solche Namen sind ja immer quasi Akronyme, Abkürzungen für irgendwas, aber die werden dann immer wieder so gewählt, dass oft auch ein bekanntes Wort, das es im Iraner saß auf Spanisch, so viel wie Blicke. Ja, das ist also dann ein.
Und Dosiere ist so ägyptischer.
Genau der ist ein griechischer Normen, nach der griechischen Stadt hin und her ähm und Mira, das wird
äh hat dann eben die Spezialität, dass es im neuen Fall bei sehr hoher Auflösung beobachten kann, also auch bei einer spektakulären Auflösung von ungefähr 20tausend und mit einem äh speziellen System von 12 Robo
Armen, dann zwölf Objekte gleichzeitig in seinem Gesichtsfeld beobachten kann.
Okay. Okay, aber das ist ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik, das muss erstmal äh gebaut und installiert werden.
Ist äh gut dabei ist äh wird zur Zeit abgeschlossen. Das ist also ein Instrument des Anderen Florida entwickelt und gebaut worden ist und jetzt eben äh ja oder fertiggestellt wird und jetzt
äh dann im Mai beziehungsweise Juni dann auf La Palma ankommen soll und dann bei uns dann installiert wird.
Okay. Also es ist viel Bewegung in dem äh in dem Standort, so,
Grob kommt zum Einsatz. Wenn ich grad äh Vulkan ausbricht oder schlechtes Wetter ist,
Ähm die Instrumente, die jetzt sind, die sind kommen halt zum Einsatz, aber über die nächsten Jahre wird es sich sozusagen noch äh ja nicht verbessern. Ja doch verbessern, also es wird sozusagen noch vielfältiger äh werden und kann noch mehr Wissenschaft unterstützen.
Ja, lass uns doch noch mal kurz darüber sprechen, wie das jetzt eigentlich so konkret,
aussieht und das geht ja dann auch mehr jetzt auf deine eigentliche Tätigkeit als äh Supporter. Wie muss man sich so diesen Betrieb des Teleskops vorstellen? Als ich jetzt da war, gut, das war halt jetzt.
Nicht im Betrieb so, dann war das eine relativ dünne äh Personaldecke, was nicht wie voll's da oben
Ball wird, aber es muss halt immer jemand da sein, aber ähm derzeit werden ja nicht so viele Leute gebraucht oder sind es immer nur so zwei, drei Leute, die da äh rumhängen um diesen ganzen Apparat zu betreiben?
Na ja, da hast du vielleicht äh ein bissel den falschen Eindruck gekriegt bei deinem Besuch, ja,
Ähm du bist einfach mit dem äh Team in der Nacht äh äh zusammengetroffen, ja in der Nacht, wenn beobachtet wird, sind's einfach zwei Personen dann, ja? Sogenannte Telescope, äh und ein Astronom, ja.
Team des Dom beobachtet, ja. Ist an ähm kleineren Teleskopen ist alles äh,
wesentlich einfacher und da beobachte ich dann auch nur eine Person, ja,
Während dann quasi im Team äh tagsüber dann ebenso an neuen Standhaltung arbeitet oder an äh eben an Arbeitende dann eben für neue Instrumente was vorbereiten und solche Sachen. Also da gibt's es gibt immer was zu.
Sozusagen, ja.
Instandhaltung, Vorbereitung, Entwicklung, und so weiter. Also da gibt's immer was zu tun. Also wie gesagt, in der Nacht wird beobachtet und äh unter Tags äh wird dann eben Instandhaltung gemacht, Innere Arbeit
und so weiter. Also da ist äh es ist ähm,
arbeite dann immer auch eine Gruppe von einem Dutzend oder mehr Leuten, dann sind dann also eher Ingenieure, ja,
Informatiker, Software natürlich auch ja äh.
Nicht unbedingt immer alle vor Ort sein. Ich meine, um da hoch zu kommen, das ist ja echt schon eine ganz schöne Reise.
Das ist äh das ist ja dann so die ähm die, die unter Tags dort arbeiten, die fahren dann in der Früh rauf eine Stunde, arbeiten dann äh ein paar Stunden und fahren dann wieder runter, ja?
Stunde bleibt. Ich habe anderthalb Stunden gebraucht, bin's auch hoch.
Genau, genau, ja ja.
Okay, gut, aber jetzt für für die eigentliche Durchführung der Beobachtung, also vielleicht können wir ja mal diesen Prozess ähm ein wenig beschreiben, vor allem wie das dann sozusagen,
für die Wissenschaft sich auch äh darstellt. Also wenn ich jetzt Wissenschaftler wäre, ich denke mir so, oh ja hier diesen Stern,
genauer anschauen und ihr habt auch da das passende Teleskop und das passende Instrument. Lasst mich doch da mal eine Stunde draufglotzen, um,
Daten zu sammeln, dann äh würde ich wahrscheinlich einen Antrag schreiben und sagen so hier äh hätte ich gern mach doch mal.
Ja, es gibt eben so die Zeit wird auch so in Semestern eingeteilt.
Also Hallenobservatorien. Ja, sozusagen Wintersemester und Sommersemester. Also entweder dann von Beweise zum Beispiel von Oktober bis ähm,
bis März geht, Winter und von April bis September im im Sommer dann,
auch den ein oder anderen Monat verschoben zum Beispiel geht's Wintersemester von September bis äh Februar und dann von März bis August
und es sprechend zu diesen äh Semestern gibt's äh dann eben auch einen sogenannten,
also quasi dann eine Deadline, wo ähm dann eben die also auf Deutsch die Beobachtungsanträge dann äh eingereicht werden können,
Das ist eigentlich an allen observatorien so. Das ist bei der Iso so mit den ganzen, die haben zweimal im Jahr äh eine Deadline, wo man dann für für sämtliche Esoteliskope dann da Anträge schreiben kann,
und ähm das bei allen anderen Teleskopen, auch bei sämtlichen Teleskopen hier auf La Palma äh so unter anderen Observatoren auf der Welt,
zweimal im Jahr da eine Deadline gibt, um äh einzureichen dann fürs Semester drauf, ja und ähm.
Gibt's eine Jury, die guck.
Eben ja gibt verschiedene Namen dann auf Englisch also zum Beispiel typischerweise heißt es dann also,
das dann eben die Anträge dann ja begutachtet und dann eine Auswahl trifft, ja. Es wird da deutlich mehr Zeit beantragt, das überhaupt zur Verfügung steht, ja.
Meine von der Seite im Prinzip in den Nächten zur Verfügung steht so das Jahr über, ja, da geht er schon mal einen Teil davon äh durch schlechtes Wetter verloren,
oder auch mal durch einen Vulkanausbruch, wie wir es jetzt gehabt haben, ja. Aber selbst äh jetzt äh theoretisch in dem hypothetisch Fall, der leider nie eintritt, dass es nur gutes Wetter gibt und man jede Nacht ähm,
das alles beobachten könnte. Selbst dann könnte man nicht alles beobachten, was ertragt wird. Also da dieser sogenannte Oversibscription. Das ist äh gerade bei ähm
so wichtig ist wie bei der Jesu zum Beispiel oder so ist, der kann durchaus so ein Faktor vier oder fünf sein, ja.
Vier oder fünfmal mehr angenommen wird.
Mehr so viel beobachtet äh beantragt wird als ähm überhaupt machbar wäre, ja.
Im ersten Schritt schon bei der bei der.
Genau, also genau, also da wo quasi für ein äh quasi wenn da sämtliche Anträge, die eingereicht werden äh,
Beantragen also in der Summe es so viel Zeit, dass man dafür 4 oder fünf Semester brauchen wird. Also nur für eins.
Oder fünf Teleskope.
Wird also schon mal eine eine Vorauswahl getroffen, eben durch das äh durch das Komitee und wäre dann überhaupt ein welche Anträge dann überhaupt angenommen werden, ja
Der wird also schon mal einige viele aussortiert, müssen aussortiert werden, ja also da wird quasi so ein wissenschaftliches Ranking gemacht, also
wird eigentlich dann mehr so dieser sogenannte Science Case bewertet. Also so wie die Wissenschaftler. Also wie gut das quasi begründet wird, wie interessant,
wissen die wovon die sprechen? Ist das interessant? Ist das gut begründet? Können sie das machen? Wie viel auch wie viele Publikationen die schon haben, sagt man ja, sind die auf dem Gebiet aktiv, äh haben die was aus der früheren Beobachtungen gemacht? Dann wird's auch wieder erleichtert ist zu.
Ähm das dann bewilligt zu kriegen und so nach das sind dann natürlich auch wieder subjektive Kriterien, aber,
Gut. Sind ja auch nur Menschen, ja und die müssen dann äh da eben da zum Teil Hunderte Anträge dann äh da lesen und dann eben Ranking machen.
Dafür uns selbst dann äh von dem, was dann eben angenommen wird, kann er dann auch wieder nicht alles äh.
Genau, darauf wollte ich nämlich jetzt gerade äh ansprechen so, also
Wenn man jetzt solche Ausfälle hat, schlechtes Wetter, es kann was nicht genommen werden, dann äh und das ist ja dann sozusagen Teil des,
Prozesses, der dann eben jenseits dieses äh TACs oder wie auch immer das Komitee heißt, abläuft der ja Teil eures Daily Jobs ist und das heißt, ihr habt quasi so eine Liste mit, das müsst ihr jetzt mal alles gemacht werden,
Schaut mal jetzt so drauf und dann muss es ja irgendwie auch erstmal passen. Es muss ja irgendwie alles zum richtigen
Zeitpunkt äh muss ja auch irgendwie sichtbar sein, was da beobachtet werden soll. Und jetzt will man ja auch wahrscheinlich das Teskop die ganze Zeit für jede Beobachtung stundenlang durch die Gegend fahren, sondern man versucht das so zu gruppieren, weiß nicht genau, aber das sind alles so Faktoren, die da mit reinkommen, oder?
Genau, das sind alles schon sehr wichtige Aspekte, die du jetzt gerade erwähnt hast, an dem an dem Punkt sollten wir vielleicht einen kleinen Einschub machen und ähm,
Unterschied zwischen äh verschiedenen Beobachtungsmoden erklären. Also worauf ich jetzt raus will, ist eben der Unterschied zwischen sogenannten Visita Mode und Service.
Gerade in früheren Zeiten
und heute auch noch bei kleineren Teleskopen war's so, dass man eben Beobachtungszeit beantragt hat und dann genommen äh worden ist, eben bestimmte Nächte dafür zugewiesen bekommen hat, ja. Welche Nächte das sind oder welche äh
dann das äh,
natürlich auch mit der Sichtbarkeit der Objekte zusammen, dann natürlich mit den Koordinaten Nächte im im Mai oder im September oder so oder wenn eben die Objekte über,
in den größeren Bereichen verteilt sind, dann eben äh vielleicht der ein oder andere noch den einen Monat und noch äh welche in einem anderen Monat dann, ja?
Quasi das Teleskop dann noch in bestimmten Nächten eben dann bestimmt
Antragstellern dann zugewiesen, die dann eben auch dann auch selber dann angereist sind, um dann selber ihre Beobachtungen durchzuführen, ja. Deswegen habe ich auch dann auch der warme Wisse jetzt ermordet, ja. Das war eigentlich über viele Jahrzehnte oder in früheren Zeiten war das so das ganz normale, ja?
Da ist man dann auch vor Ort.
Da ist man dann eben auch vor Ort, da reißt man dann selber an, wenn man dann bewilligt gekriegt hat für die Zeit und beobachtet dann auch selber, ja?
Und ähm,
Es hat aber dann auch den Nachteil, ganz abgesehen davon, dass man dann reisen muss. Gut, man kann's auch so sehen, dass man äh dass man dann verreisen kann, beziehungsweise darf und dann auch das Vergnügen hat, dann auch selber mal da.
Zu beobachten, aber es hat ihm natürlich auch den Nachteil, das Wetter in den Nächten.
Was es ist, ja. Hört sich sehr banal an, wenn ich das so sage. Das ist aber in der Tat so, ja, wenn das äh wenn dann da schlechtes Wetter ist. Also das heißt, es ist bewölkt oder es regnet oder sonst was, dann dann sind die Nächte verloren, ja?
Das ist wirklich, also das ist wirklich äh dann so eine Art Lotterie, ja. Da da hat man dann wirklich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Pech gehabt.
Man kann dann natürlich und geht ohne Datenheim dann, ja? Oder man verliert einen Teil, also sagen wir mal, man hat zum Beispiel vier Nächte, einen davon ist schlechtes Wetter
und in zweien davon ist gutes Wetter und man kann beobachten. Da geht man also mit weniger Beobachtungen heim, was wir eigentlich machen wollte oder beantragt gehabt hat einfach ja einfach nicht. Natürlich kann man dann wieder einen Antrag schreiben für ein kommendes Semester.
Erwähnen, dass der das schon mal angenommen worden ist und dass das halt durch schlechtes Wetter verlorengegangen ist. Also es ist dann natürlich eine Frau, aber man sieht an dem Beispiel jetzt schon,
dass es äh schwierig sein kann und langwieriger Prozess sein kann, bis man beobachtet, in dem man durchführen möchte, dann tatsächlich komplett durchgeführt hat. Ja, das kann sich also über mehrere Semester, über mehrere Jahre stricken, dann auch wenn man Pech hat, beziehungsweise wenn auch dann Anträge zum Teil muss man nicht angenommen werden, ja?
Wie gesagt, wenn äh vier bis fünf Mal so viel Zeit beantragt wird als äh verfügbar ist oder überhaupt angenommen werden kann, äh ist es äh eigentlich,
In den allermeisten Fällen so, dass es immer wahrscheinlicher ist, dass ein Antrag nicht angenommen wird, als das angenommen wird. Das heißt also, man verbringt dann oft manchmal äh mehrere Semester, bis man den Antrag,
kriegt, ja? Man nimmt danach immer wieder das Feed
dann so her und sagt, wie kann man den Antrag verbessern und so, bis er dann mal angenommen wird oder manchmal gibt man dann auch einfach auf, wenn er, wenn er fünfmal hintereinander dann ähm abgelehnt worden ist, ja, das kenne ich selber aus eigener Erfahrung, ja?
So ist das dann halt.
Ja und dann äh das ist dann eben auch dann so ein Nachteil von diesem äh sogenannten Vicitimell, dass eben das Wetter ist es, was es ist und ähm ja.
Die Alternative dazu ist der Service-Mode.
Genau, das ist also wird also das besonders in den letzten 20 Jahren, ist das immer mehr aufgekommen, grad an den größeren Teleskopen.
Aber zum Zelt sogar einen kleineren Teleskop, aber so einen kleineren Teleskop mehr eigentlich noch sehr weit verbreitet. Wir sind die heutige Zeit
Ähm aber gerade in größeren Teleskopen, wie eben den äh VIPs bei der Eso und eben auch
Auch den Keck-Teleskopen und anderen großen Teleskopen so von acht Meter Durchmesser bis eben zu den großen Seemeter Tennisgruppen, wie eben grande kann. Ist eben die sogenannte Service-Motor, dann ist der hauptsächliche Modus. Das heißt also, dass
derjenige, der Beobachtungen beantragt hat, dann eben nicht mehr selber dorthin verreist und mit dem Teleskop selber in einer bestimmten Nacht zu beobachten
sondern die Beobachtungen werden eben beantragt, dann eben.
Ausgewählt von dem äh Komitee, aber dann eben nicht für bestimmte Nächte eingeteilt, äh sondern da hat man dann eben äh wie du gerade erwähnt hast, so eine lange Liste an äh angenommenen Anträgen.
Der dann eben so Stück für Stück abgearbeitet wird, beziehungsweise abgearbeitet werden können, ja. Das heißt, es ist dann also nicht von vorneherein klar, wenn äh,
so beantragte Beobachtungen dort ausgeführt werden, dann ist es von vornherein nicht klar, wann die dann beobachtet werden. Aber genau diese Flexibilität ist eben der große Vorteil,
äh von diesem Modus, dass man dann eben äh,
wenn eben die Bedingungen dafür günstig sind, ja? Beziehungsweise die Bedingungen sind ja dann eben auch ein Teil von dem Antrag, weil äh so beim klassischen Visitamol ist es ja so, man kriegt das jetzt grad zu bewiesen und die Bedingungen sind, was sie sind, also nicht nur, ob's später
gut ist oder schlecht, sondern ähm.
Spielt natürlich auch eine Rolle, ja? Äh für Beobachtungen im optischen Bereich ist äh sind Mundlose nicht besser als äh Nächte mit einem helleren Mund oder sogar Vollmond.
Ja, weil der Himmelshintergrund bei äh mit dem hellen Mond wesentlich heller ist als äh eben ohne Mond.
Während äh im Infrarot ist es so, dass der Himmelshintergrund nicht von der Mondphase abhängt.
Der Himmelshintergrund sowieso deutlich heller als im optischen Bereich.
Und hängt obendrein nicht von der groß von der Mondphase ab. Also das Himmelshintergrund bei Vollmondungen genauso hell wie bei Neumond.
Deswegen ist also allein schon in der Einteilung jetzt eben bei dem klassischen Visittermode
äh eben für eher mondlose oder nicht oder nicht mit wenig Mund eben typischerweise eher optischer Beobachtungen angesetzt werden und Infrarotbeobachtungen dann eher um Vollmond drum, weil der Vollmond da nicht stört.
Und äh aber auch beim Service-Mode sind solche ja,
dann auch wichtig. Also da gibt man dann äh bei dem Antrag auch an, welche Bedingungen machen, dass da grad bei optischen Beobachtungen, besonders bei schwachen Objekten äh ganz danach wichtig sein, dass man eben Mondlose Nächte hat.
Beziehungsweise den anderen Beobachtungen, die sind dann net so streng, da kann man dann auch bissel Mond haben und so
spielt der Mundphase wieder keine Rolle und ähm abgesehen von der Mundphase spielt er natürlich auch das Sägen eine Rolle, ja. Weil's jetzt net,
äh ob der Begriff äh ja also mit äh dem Begriff Siegen äh äh wird eigentlich die Luft und Ruhe bezeichnet.
Ja, also wir wir sehen ja quasi durch unsere Atmosphäre durch, ja
Ja das Licht, das uns von äh von da draußen erreicht. Das muss erst mal die die Erdmastmosphäre durch, dieses Zahn aus Teleskop trifft
Und äh je nachdem, wie ruhig die Atmosphäre ist, äh sind eben die Abbildungen von Punktquellen mehr oder weniger ja,
salopp gesagt verschmiert,
Ja, also äh Sterne sind da quasi wirklich äh sehr gute Punktquellen, ja. Das ist also wirklich so klein, dass also so äh,
ja wie gesagt ist eben eine Punkte. Ist aber jetzt nicht beliebig klein dann auch auf dem Detektor, sondern wird eben durch die Luft und Ruhe auf eben so einen,
so ein kleines Scheibchen zusammen verschmiert ja und dieser dieser Effekt wird eben mit dem Griff siegen äh bezeichnet
beziehungsweise Siegen ist dann eben auch der Zahlenwert wie äh wie groß dann eben dieses äh ja dieses
Scheibchen, dann dann ist auf dem auf das eben dann.
Man möchte diesen Zahlenwert.
Genau deshalb die genaue Definition zu erwähnen
Bereich von einer Bogensekunde oder so. Also damit man da so ein äh so eine Vorstellung davon kriegt. Also alles, was klein ist als eine Bogensekunde, ist schon eigentlich schon sehr gutes Seeing, ja.
Und so ab zwei Bogen Sekunden drüber, das ist dann eigentlich schon sehr schlecht, ja. Es sind dann schlechter ist und dann äh,
das Licht auf äh größere Fläche verteilt wird,
geht auch äh natürlich auch räumliche Auflösung verloren. Das ist aber jetzt kein allzu wichtiger Effekt. Was wichtiger ist,
dann irgendwie ihr schlechtes Singen ist, desto weniger tief kann er Beobachtung werden. Also dann äh wir sind dann quasi schwächere Objekte, dann schwerer zu detektieren.
Insgesamt geht dann äh dann das sogenannte Signal, also das Signal Rauschverhältnis äh äh geht bei schlechterem Singen dann immer mit runter.
Ja, das ist eigentlich da so der Hauptschutzgrund. Bei Spektroskopie kommt dann natürlich noch
das äh dazu, was ich vorher grad erwähnt habe, dann ist der sogenannte Slitgloss. Da äh nimmt er dann das Licht äh selektiert man dann mit diesem,
und so einen Spalt hat dann eben dann so eine eine Breite, die dann immer am Himmel dann so typischerweise vielleicht,
Sekunde entspricht oder so, da hat man dann eben verschiedene Sportbreiten, wie ich vorher gerade erwähnt habe, also zum Beispiel eine Bergung, Sekunde, anderthalb Punkte, Sekunde oder sowas. Und klar, je schlechter das Siegen ist, desto mehr Licht geht dann natürlich verloren außerhalb äh vor dem,
ja? Also das sind jetzt so die hauptsächlichen Effekte, warum eben äh besseres Ding eben immer besser.
Besser sehen ist immer.
Aber je nach je nach Anforderungen von den Beobachtungen, also das heißt also wenn man relativ helle Objekte hat, dann spielt vielleicht weniger eine Rolle, als wenn man sehr schwache Objekte hat. Das heißt also, je nach Anforderungen gibt's eben äh,
Beobachtungen, die wirklich dunkle Nächte brauchen, mondlose Nächte, dann welche, die eben ein bissel Mund zulassen und welche, bei denen Mondphase egal ist. Sei es eben weit Objekt
so hell sind oder weil's eben Beobachtungen sind, wo der Mundphase keine Rolle spielt
Und dann hat man eben auch Anforderungen an See. Es gibt Beobachtungen, die sind also anspruchsvoll und da braucht man wirklich sehr gute
deutlich besser als eine Bogensekunde und dann welche, die eher so mittlere Anforderungen haben, wo man sagt, okay, bis 1 Komma2 oder 1,5 Bogensekunden ist noch okay und welche, die eigentlich äh auch mal schlechten Sinn gemacht werden können, also zwei Punktsekunden oder sowas, ja.
Wir haben also alle Anträge, da die Beantragung dann eben nicht nur bestimmten äh wie sagt man auf Deutsch amount amount of ti
äh der hier bestimmte Menge Zeit dann beantragen, sondern eben auch dann diese auf die Beobachtungsbedingungen angeben, sprich äh Mondphase, Sing
und auch Transparenz, also ob die wirklich einen ganz klaren Himmel brauchen oder ob auch äh quasi äh mit dünnen Wolken, ob's dann auch noch geht, ja, also mit dünnen Wolk
so zirren kann man auch noch beobachten, ja, das nimmt dann eben eben bissel Licht weg, hat man dann bissel mehr Extinktion beziehungsweise zusammen mit Mondlicht heißt es dann auch, dass die Wolken dann äh Mondlicht reflektieren und dadurch den Himmelshintergrund erhöhen.
Wie ist denn das mit mit solchen Effekten wie.
Starlink äh Starts, ja, wo dann auf einmal so eine ganze Kette äh von Satelliten über den äh Himmel zieht. Hat man das so auf auf der auf der Kette irgendwie, weiß man das, dass das irgendwie passieren wird oder äh seid ihr dann von sowas vielleicht auch mal überrascht?
Satelliten sind äh sicher und sehr interessantes Thema. Ähm ist nämlich so, dass äh wenn dann am Ende alle gestartet sind, äh soweit ich weiß, äh sind nur da 40.000 Satelliten geplant.
Und äh wenn man jetzt bedenkt, dass der der gesamte Himmel quasi also die Himmelskugel ja entspricht äh ungefähr 41.000 Quadrat, ja.
Genau einundvierzigtausendzweihundertdreiundfünfzig ungefähr, ja?
Das heißt also 40.000 Satelliten heißt also, dass also über den Himmel verteilt im Schnitt in einem Quadrat grad am Himmel sich ein solcher Satelliter befindet, ja.
Nicht unbedingt sichtbar sein muss, aber.
Aber so ungefähr, das heißt also das dann doch relativ dicht. Die sind zum Teil auch mit bloßen Auge sichtbar, also das ist schon ein großes Problem. Es ist ein ästhetisches Problem, ja und ja,
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dann einer während der Beobachtung durchs Gesichtsfeld durchfliegt, die ist doch relativ hoch.
Das ist auch schon passiert, ja. Also ich habe jetzt vor ich glaube das war vor ungefähr zwei Jahren habe ich da mal in der Beobachtung während einer
Nacht, wo ich keine Nachtschicht gehabt habe, habe ich da quasi per Zufall so ein Spektrum eingefangen daher war eine spektoskopische Beobachtung und dann zieht eben äh so ein Sate,
durch das Gesichtsfeld durch. Jetzt klar, ich meine diesen äh schmalen Spalt, der so vielleicht so eine Bogensekunde Breite hat,
natürlich in den winzigen Sekundenbruchteil durch, aber
die Objekte, die sind ja so hell, dass man es äh dann auch mit bloß ein Auge sehen kann und so ein helles Objekt bei so einem großen Teleskop, das hinterlässt also selbst in der kurzen Zeit von den Sekunden
Bruchteil für ein schönes Spektrum, ja? Da haben wir also dann abgesehen von den Objekten, der den der Beobachtung da beobachtet werden sollten, da hat man halt dann quasi an einer anderen Punkt vor dem vor dem Spalter, nach dem Detektor hat man dann noch extra Speck drin.
Aber das passiert ja nur, wenn der äh Satellit in dem Moment auch tatsächlich Licht reflektiert über die äh Solarpanele. Das tut er ja nicht unbedingt immer. Ähm Spasics wollte ja da irgendwie was auch gegen Unternehmen, ich glaube in einer Beschichtung oder mit einer etwas äh ange
passten Solarpanel.
Ja und dann reflektieren's mehr im Infrarot und das ist dann doch ein größeres Problem.
Ihr seid nicht glücklich mit Starlig. Lasst es mich so sagen.
Hast du vollkommen Recht.
Stier. Ähm so um so mal ein bisschen äh zusammenfassen. Also wir haben jetzt
quasi die Vorphase äh
ja betrachtet, also Wissenschaftler müssen Antrag schreiben, müssen sagen, okay, das macht doch alles total Sinn, ist total wichtig, was ich hier mache und die Zukunft der Menschheit hängt im Wesentlichen äh davon äh ab, dann gibt's halt irgendein äh Komitee, das segnet das ab und sagt okay prima, das machen wir's, weil,
Drauf, Rettung der Menschheit und so und dann äh kommt das quasi in die Liste. Und dann eines schönen Tages, wenn das ähm vorgesehen ist in diesem Semester für den jeweiligen Beobachtungstag und wenn dann irgendwie auch noch alles passt so, dann,
Sozusagen auf der äh Liste. Das ist ja dann sozusagen auch so ein bisschen so Daily Job, ne? Das ist ja dann sozusagen so für eine Beobachtungsnacht.
Bei Sonnenteleskopen wär's ja dann auch mal der Tag, aber im Falle vom GTC ist es halt dann äh äh die Nacht, dann dann liegt sozusagen alles äh auf dem Tisch, was ähm,
Beobachtet werden soll, wie.
Wie priorisiert man das jetzt, dass dass womit fängt man sozusagen an, weil die widersprechen sich ja unter Umständen auch so ein bisschen. Die einen wollen in die Richtung gucken, die anderen wollen in die Richtung äh.
Na ja, also mit der Richtung ist er quasi ähm dann verschiedene Objekte, weil wie gesagt, die Objekte, die bewegen sich ja äh übern Himmel wegen der Erdrutation.
Schon eben bei dem Thema äh eben bei der Sichtbarkeit, ja? Das äh eben äh was zu welchem Zeitpunkt in der Nacht und im Jahr eben beobachtbar ist, ja? Im Winter
beobachtet sind oder im Sommer äh oder am Anfang in der Nacht oder danach ist er. Im Prinzip äh sind ja Objekte, die grad äh sehr nah an der Sonne sind, sind im Prinzip unbeobachtbar, weil sie eben in der Nacht unterm Horizont sind oder
eben am Anfang der Nacht schon zu tief stehen oder am Ende danach noch zu tief stehen,
Das heißt also, jedes äh Objekt hat halt so eine Beobachtungs äh so einem Zeitraum äh im Jahr, wo's beobachtet werden kann, wo's also am Anfang nur am Ende in der Nacht, am Morgenhimmel beobachtet werden kann, wenn's schon langsam raufkommt.
Dann äh zur besten Zeit, wo es eben äh ungefähr in der Mitte der Nacht kuliniert und nach der Vor und der Nacht beobachtbar ist.
Die beste Sichtbarkeit und dann eben danach noch äh immer noch in der ersten Nachtäft, hat am Anfang von der Nacht, ja
auch von der Dekination ab, also Objekte, die sehr weit im Norden stehen, haben eine eine weitere,
längere Sichtbarkeitsspanne während Objekte sehr weit im Süden sind nicht nur
relativ tief überm Horizont stehen, sondern eben auch kürzere Beobachtungs äh oder Sichtbarkeitsperioden haben eben
und dann äh spielt als nächstes dann natürlich die Beobachtungsbedingungen eine Rolle, ja?
Mondphase weiß man ja im vornherein, das ist von vornherein klar, also jetzt ist eine Neumondnacht ist, dann kann man wirklich die ganze Nacht der Beobachtungen machen, die Mondlosen äh äh mondlosen Himmel erfordern.
Und wenn sie in der Vollmondnacht ist, dann kann man eben zum Beispiel dann eben Infrarotbeobachtungen machen oder andere Beobachtungen, die eben keinerlei äh Restriktionen zur Mondphase haben, die sagen, okay, Vollmond ist auch okay.
Was man eben nicht vorher weiß, ist es sehen, ja? Ob man in der Nacht das da gute hat oder schlechtes Singen und das verändert sich auch zum Teil äh zum Teil, ja? Es kann sein, dass man die ganze Nacht durch gute Singen hat. Es kann sein, dass man die ganze Nacht durch schlechtes Singen hat oder zuerst Gutes oder schlechtes oder umgekehrt und so weiter. Das halt
vorher nicht genau weiß, ja und deswegen hat man da eben auch verschiedene Pläne eigentlich für die verschiedenen Szenarien.
Also was man beobachten würde, ein gutes Singen ist oder mittelmäßiges Singen oder schlechtes Singen. Deswegen weiß man eben vor der Nacht
genau, was man dann wirklich beobachten wird. Weil man immer ja für verschiedene sind und eben verschiedene Pläne hat.
Und äh beziehungsweise auch für die Transparenz, ob wir jetzt noch eine klare Nacht ist oder ob man den Wolken hat.
Aber das erfordert ja alles auch wirklich richtig Nachtarbeit, ne, also man ist dann eigentlich im Wesentlichen nachts am arbeiten oder lässt sich alles vorher planen und läuft dann äh mehr oder weniger automatisch ab.
Ja, also man man hat halt dann so seine Vorgaben, ja eben wie gesagt einerseits die Prioritäten und andererseits die Beobachtungsbedingungen, ja?
Das sind die Kriterien, nach denen man zu jedem Zeitpunkt in der Nacht dann auswendliche Beobachtungen dann als nächstes gemacht wird, ja. Vielleicht erwähnen, dass ja alle Beobachtungen in sogenannten unterteilt sind.
Das heißt also, wenn jetzt da ähm ein Beobachtungsprogramm,
Es sind ja meistens auch mehrere Objekte. Das ist natürlich klar, dass dann für jedes Objekt dann ein Beobachtungsblock ist dann oder auch mehrere, ja? Also so ein Observing-Blog, der ist ja typischerweise auf Maximum von einer Stunde beschränkt.
Schon alleine aus dem Grund, weil's ja auch die Beobachtungsbedingungen ändern können, ja. Also man sagt, eine Stunde, das ist so ja, das ist so eine sinnvolle Übung, wo man sagt, da könnten die Bedingungen einigermaßen konst
sein, aber wie gesagt, es kann auch es kann auch jederzeit das Wetter schlecht werden, es kann sich ändern, also von gut auf schlecht sozusagen, ja?
Dann aber so wenn wenn man wenn so eine so ein Block äh nicht länger ist als eine Stunde, dann ist das äh kann man das eigentlich sehr gut managen, ja.
Aber ist das dann alles automatisiert? Äh also kann das System selber die Qualität des messen oder ist das äh etwas, wo man daneben sitzen muss und in den Himmel guckt, das ist aber jetzt echt mal ein schlechtes Ziegen hier.
Ja, im Ende ist es dann, dass du nur um selber da eigentlich dann die Entscheidung trifft, eben äh auf Grundlage dieser ja äußeren Bedingungen und der Vorgaben, ja? Man hat halt da die verschiedenen Optionen und je nach äh.
Du redest jetzt von diesem Visiter Modus, wenn die wenn die Astronomen selber vor Ort sind oder.
Sprechen jetzt eigentlich äh eigentlich nur vom Servicepart, ja? Visita Mode heißt, dass äh eben äh der Antrag stellt, dass Teleskop zugewiesen hat für die Nacht und äh dann kann er dann im Grunde im Prinzip beobachten, was er.
Aber ich wollte ja darauf hinaus, du musst einfach du musst aber vor Ort sein, du musst sozusagen in der Nacht da sein, du machst Nachtarbeit.
Ich mache ja quasi diesen ich mache genau diesen Service für die Community eben. Da Beobachtungen durchzuführen, die andere Leute eben beobachtet haben, ja. Die ganze Nacht, ja.
Wie viel Uhr bis wie viel Uhr bist du da? Also du bist eigentlich immer immer nachts am Arbeiten.
Nicht immer nur wenn ich Nachtschicht habe, ja, wir sind ja verschiedene äh mehrere Astronomen äh da und wechseln uns immer da bei den Nachtschichten ab.
Okay,
nur um das mal so ein bisschen äh vorzustellen. Es ist nicht nur so, man man tut das alles einen Computer und dann macht das Teleskop die ganze Nacht einfach, dass alles automatisch und,
automatisch oh das Sealing ist aber jetzt doof oder das Wetter passt jetzt nicht. Das ist schon etwas, wo man aktiv begleiten muss, wo man äh
Händchen halten muss mit dem Apparat und dann äh unter Umständen auch vor Ort konkret äh Entscheidungen fällen muss, so nach dem Motto diese Beobachtung ist durchzuführen
überhaupt gar keinen Sinn, weil da eben die Parameter zu schlecht sind, während diese andere Beobachtung, die man stattdessen jetzt tun könnte, die vielleicht erst für morgen geplant war, aber jetzt genauso gut auch jetzt durchgeführt werden könnte, weil's halt auch passt, dass man die jetzt irgendwie vorzieht und dann macht man die andere später oder so.
Ja, so ähnlich kannst du das in der Tat vorstellen, ja? Wie ich grad schon erwähnt habe, man weiß am äh Vorternacht nicht wirklich, was man am Ende wirklich beobachten wird, ja? Man hat also für die verschiedenen Szenarien eben verschiedene Pläne und dann ja.
So ein Star Jockey so ein bisschen, so wie so Discjockey, die passende Musik für die Besucher äh aussucht.
Ja, sind.
Grob mit dem Plan reinkommt, aber dann immer wieder anpassen muss so. Ja okay.
Interessanter Vergleich, glaube ich, Sie sind der Tatort so, ja? Dann äh kann doch mal sein, dass in der äh in der Nacht das Wetter schlecht wird und man dann zumachen muss, weil Wolken aufkommen oder ist es regnen beginnt? Kann's einfach sein, dass das schlechte Wetter wieder weg
geht und dann kann man äh kann man wieder weitermachen, also es kann sein, dass ein Teil der Nacht verloren geht äh wegen schlechtem,
und dann wenn man wieder aufmacht, dann schauen wir, okay, wo ist man gerade? Wir sind jetzt die Bedingungen, wo macht man jetzt weiter und so weiter, also man macht dann eben äh in so einer Nacht dann eben auch
verschiedene Blöcke von verschiedenen Beobachtungsprogrammen da ja? Macht man einen Block für für dieses Programm, einen Block für jenes Programm und so weiter ja?
Wenn dir das alles gut gelaufen ist und die Beobachtungen durchgeführt worden sind, dann läuft's aber mehr oder weniger automatisch. Die Daten werden von dem äh Apparat gesammelt und dann wird's gleich als.
Auch auch nicht so wirklich automatisch, also wir haben das so, dass äh äh dann tagsüber ein anderer Kollege dann im Büro dann eben äh Qualitätskontrolle macht, ja.
Überprüft, ob da alles in Ordnung ist.
Sondern auch die Anforderungen erfüllt sind, ja. Die san normalerweise der Fall, aber das ist quasi nochmal so ein ja eben wie gesagt Qualitätskontrolle, ja. Ähm
Also wirklich nur gute Daten, wo alles passt, dann eben dann auch an die an der Anlaufstelle verschickt.
Dann wird das eben heutzutage einfach auf den FDP hochgeladen. Die kriegen dann eine E-Mail-Benachrichtigung, können sich die Daten dann runterladen, ne.
Geht ja eigentlich die wissenschaftliche Arbeit erst richtig äh los und davon äh erfahrt ihr natürlich erst sehr viel später.
Ja, typischerweise ähm,
Wenn man mal so einen kompletten Datensatz hat äh oder was halt die jeweiligen Antragsteller halt so braucht oder will, ja ähm dann dauert's ähm typischerweise das äh.
Ein Jahr oder sogar mehr, bis dann eben aus äh Beobachtungen dann mal Resultate gibt und dann eine Publikation rausgibt, also bis dann PayPal geschrieben ist und dann veröffentlicht ist,
Wir werden dann natürlich benachrichtigt, weil jedes äh Observatorium hat natürlich sein seine Publikationslisten, ist ja quasi auch so eine so eine Art Gradmesser wie wie erfolgreich so ein Observatorium ist,
ich meine äh ist zwar, wie gesagt, wir machen hier.
Quasi einen Service für die Community. Also wir liefern denen die Beobachtungen äh die sie haben wollen, damit die dann ihre Wissenschaft damit machen können und
unser Job ist quasi denen gute Daten zu liefern, also quasi das zu erfüllen, was sie beantragt haben, ihre Anforderungen dann, ja und äh aber dann ist es eigentlich nimmer in unserer Hand, weil das sind ja dann wie gesagt
die Antragstelle, die dann ihre Daten haben und dann ihre Wissenschaftler mitmachen, ihre Publikationen schreiben und ja es ist auch äh,
So die Sonne, meisten Obsolationen sogar so, dass auch ein äh ziemlich großer Prozentsatzbeobachtungen dann nie publiziert wird
Und verschiedene Gründe haben, also sei es, dass ähm äh,
das ist äh aus irgendeinem Grund wird die dann nimmer interessant ist oder eben auch äh mangel an Ressourcen, dass also jemand, der an der Stelle gehabt hat, dann vielleicht die Gastronomie verlässt.
Und das dann einfach liegenbleibt oder dass das äh irgendwie für einen, keine Ahnung, für einen Doktoranden oder einen Posttag vorgesehen wird und der ist dann nimmer da oder so, der ist dann mit anderen Dingen beschäftigt oder ja, also er gibt verschiedenste Gründe, ja.
Ja, aber fallen dir ein paar Beispiele ein, wo Beobachtung jetzt mit dem GTC gemacht wurden, wo später äh interessante Wissenschaft bei rausgefallen ist, die vielleicht,
größere Aufmerksamkeit äh erlangt hat oder die äh selbst wenn nicht äh interessant war.
Also generell äh kann ich berichten, dass in denen ja doch mittlerweile bissel mehr als zehn Jahren in äh seit äh des äh in Betrieb ist.
Publikationsliste umfasst seit doch schon um die 700 ähm Referee Papers.
Und ähm ja wie ihr jetzt zum Beispiel auf unserer Website schaust, da gibt's auch einige Pressemitteilungen dann äh
also doch von so ein paar Sachen, die dann rausstechen, das umfasst die verschiedensten äh Teilbereiche in der Gastronomie, also zum Beispiel Exo Planet.
Atmosphären erwähnt, da sind manchmal zum Teil, wenn zum ersten Mal bestimmte Elemente in äh,
Der Exoplanetenatmosphäre detektiert wurden. Das war ein Kunde vom der ganzen Beobachtung gekommen da so.
Dein Interview mit meinem Kollegen Helmut zwar noch nicht gehört. Ich gehe aber sehr davon aus, dass er über,
unsere Entdeckung gesprochen hat, wo wir vor drei Jahren ungefähr den äh weitest
entfernten äh bekannten äh Galaxienhaufen im frühen Universum entdeckt haben beziehungsweise durch eine Beobachtung am Grande kann, die ich dann durchgeführt habe. Ähm den Inspektoskopisch bestätigt haben eben mit die 68 Kopie, mit.
Mhm.
Äh
da ist dann auch eine Pressemitteilung vom IAC rausgekommen und äh sogar ein paar deutschen Tageszeitungen haben wir sogar Artikel untergebracht und
Ist mal ganz nett, wenn man da auch mal dann auch mal den eigenen Namen liest dann, weil ansonsten ist ja wie gesagt die Gastronomie eigentlich so eine Art Orchideenfach, die nur ein relativ kleinen Teil der Bevölkerung äh
interessiert und insofern freuen wir uns dann über jede Gelegenheit, wo das auch mal einem größeren Publikum dann mal äh bekannt wird.
Stefan, ich sage vielen vielen Dank für deine Ausführung.
Ja, gern geschehen. War mir auch eine Freude.
Das war's hier bei Raumzeit zum Teleskopio de Kanarias, dem Grante Can. Äh ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören, ihr wisst, bald geht's wieder weiter.